this is Jocko podcast number 134 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening I come good evening maybe I
was always in the wrong place at the
wrong time I can see where someone could
get that idea but I actually don't think
that I don't think that at all
it's in fact quite the opposite now
looking back of course there were some
some tough times there were some awful
times I'd even go so far as to say there
were some wretched times there were
nights filled with discomfort and stress
and fear and there was pressure and
sometimes that pressure was so great
that I thought my mind just might
fracture and break apart
but fortunately I could tell you that I
didn't break and there were times there
were times when I saw the cracks
I saw the cracks starting to split open
and I had to work hard to keep it
together but that's the way it was in my
old line of work my old line of work had
some definite downsides because I on top
of all that pressure and stress and fear
and discomfort there was death even
during peacetime even during peacetime
I lost friends and I lost teammates it
goes with the personality profile they
would say risk takers so even peace
provided little peace and then once the
war started it just escalated not just
for me not by any stretch whatsoever
every military member has dealt with
death in some way over the past 17 years
of war some more than others there have
also been life-changing wounds of which
I was spared I was lucky
but many others were not so lucky
because the bombs and the bullets and
the IEDs and the mortars and the Rockets
they do not care who you are at all but
for whatever reason I made it through I
was lucky and now my life goes on then
maybe I'm a little more paranoid than
the next person and maybe I don't always
sleep that well and maybe there's times
when some thought or some memory catches
me off guard and I end up reliving a
moment from the past a moment from the
past that I wish I could change and you
might think wouldn't I just want to
change it all when I want to go back and
erase all that pain and replace it with
relief then replace it with ease and
with comfort
and the answer to that question is no in
fact it's not just no it's hell no
because wrapped up in that pain and
wrapped up in that discomfort and
wrapped up in that stress and anxiety
wrapped up in all that is the polar
opposites of all those feelings inside
all that turmoil there was relief there
was certainty there was happiness
there was focus and security and there
was peace a peace of mind in knowing
that no matter what no matter what
horrors befell me things would be okay
and that is because I knew that my
brothers would take care of me no matter
what you see my old job allowed me to
work with some of the best guys in the
world not all of them you've heard me
talk about that before there's
substandard people in every organization
in the world there's a bell curve and
the bottom of the bell curve is filled
with the same deficient people you'll
find anywhere
lazy scamming irresponsible
self-centered whatever
but at the high end of that bell curve
the guys I worked with were righteous
and noble and hardworking and it was
humbling to be around them now were they
perfect no none of us are did they have
flaws yes absolutely all of us fall
short but could I count on them could I
count on them without question and
without hesitation 100% through all the
horror and the fear and the pressure
there were always some guys that I knew
without a shred of doubt would stand
beside me and hold the line no matter
what they would never let me down ever
and as fate would have it I'm lucky
enough to have one of those a few men
that I knew I could always count on no
matter what here with me tonight he's
done more for me and for the teams and
for our great nation in the world is
ever going to know his name is Mike
Sorelli
he's a former recon marine the very
recently retired SEAL officer and he's
someone that's never let me down so Mike
welcome to the podcast and thanks for
coming on brother
hey Jocko happy to be hearing that go
thank you for having me so you retired
how long ago March 1st March 1st and so
no one knows anything about you which is
the way it is and so let's get to know a
little bit about you starting with the
beginning let's start in NorCal NorCal
that's what you were born right in
NorCal Palo Alto California just about
30 minutes south of San Francisco entire
family born and raised in San Francisco
they're all still back there except for
my brother whitefish montana but you
know what nothing to really lack in
terms of growing up I had a great family
you know sometimes I described growing
up in this house the Cirelli household
is being in 1960s 1950s Germany Berlin
except that was on the wrong side of the
wall
no I grew up in a very Catholic family
loving parents very very strict Stern
parents but I got the the benefit of
being the the last child and by that you
know that point the older brother and
sister they'd worn down the worn down
your parents a little bit they had worn
down my parents a little bit and so I
got away with bloody murder to a point
but you know standard you know
upbringing of a seal I had my share of
of trouble I've got a cost and that's
probably one why I want the pedo what at
what point did you at what point did you
realize that you were gonna go in the
military so you know III can't
you know pinpoint a specific moment but
everything was driving that you know
driving me that way
I did have a grandfather that was first
of the five Oh first oh well in World
War two
actually he trained with Patton out in
oh and uh yeah the lake house training
center yes who they actually trained at
the lake oh okay
near near Nylund okay Sultan Syria it's
so he'd actually hit the very early part
of Africa and then came back to the the
States when airborne and he was a
quartermaster for the first of the five
Oh says fifth I'm sorry first of the
photo first and then the last he still
went through airborne training he would
jump in with him and so he was actually
a third day of Normandy drop thing and
then fought in the the Battle of the
Bulge in the Black Forest and so that
humble confidence that he never spoke
about and so my mom would naturally tell
me stories and it wasn't until I became
a Marine that he actually you know
really revealed a lot of the stories
from from World War two and then you
know as he got older it was it was the
same stories but I would sit there and
listen for the 15th time as if it was
the first time I was you know out of
respect you know it's interesting I was
talking to Dave Burke once again today
good dude yeah good you live and we were
talking about reading about face and I
was saying hey you know when you worried
about what the the older I got the more
it meant to me and there's a quote that
from musashi that I talked about in the
podcast which is it's something like
this and I'm not gonna get it perfectly
right but it's something like this when
you know the way then you see the way in
all things
so about-face is not a leadership book
at all but when you read it and you are
thinking about leadership it's just
all about leadership it's a hundred
percent about leadership but it reminds
me of what you're saying like when
you're little when you're a kid and you
don't know the way yet and your
grandfather could be telling you these
stories and it sounds kind cool or
whatever but compared to when you
actually know and understand war and and
you it's just a totally different story
and as a matter of fact speaking to that
when you were running the Jhansi course
I was I came in and I was gonna do like
the brief that I would do to the Jhansi
course and you know you were there it
was like the tenth time you were gonna
watch it and I was like hey are you
gonna hang out watch this are you just
gonna leave and go do like work out or
something and you're like no I'm gonna
stick around and I was like why you for
what and you're like I learned something
new every time I like dig so that's
pretty uh definitely when you get older
you can appreciate some of these things
from when you know the way well let's
look at extreme ownership I mean this is
why you hear people that are like hey
I'm reading it for the seventh time yeah
because they they will get ten new
things or their perspective has changed
that's the enabler that's the part that
I didn't account for and I don't know
who told me this if somebody told me
this like it was someone that had come
to multiple musters and I said well you
know how'd you like this one and all the
monsters are a little bit different but
the first three were not that different
the first three were the same almost the
same and someone said well it's only
been a year but my perspective is
totally different now cuz I've been
promoted one time and I got different
situations going on so it's I'm seeing
it differently so that's that's another
thing that happens as you get again
older so back to you how did you pick
the Marine Corps or did the Marine Corp
review a little bit of both out of
options
no hey so you standard again high school
sports loved running loved wrestling the
grades not so much it wasn't for a lack
of aptitude it was a lack of complete
effort yeah and so you know loved to
party mmm if it didn't have to do with
parties or girls I wasn't involved yeah
and so I actually was the only one in my
high school class not to graduate
yes and my mom is a little Italian woman
and she you know she really is the rock
of the family and you have to know how
to play her but my dad is just the
disciplinarian you feared him yeah you
just feared him bottom line but you know
my mom was a nurturer and a
disciplinarian you just had to play both
sides because once you put her on to the
disciplinarian side you just had no safe
huh
safe house whatsoever anywhere in the
Sorella household so they did you know
my dad had served in Vietnam and the
reserves he did not have to go to
Vietnam because he had a very unique
skill he was very good at football and
back in the day he was stationed in Fort
Polk Louisiana he got assigned to the
football team that's what he did in the
the army but very different army wasn't
a fan in the military he just you know
we were different in those regards but
we're very much alike so I went off to
the University Colorado Colorado Boulder
the wait how did you do this reading
graduate high school did you get your
juice oh no no so I went went back for
the summer school summer session and
finished the requirement I'd already
been accepted into the university
Colorado the early stage of my life is
not just parents can't say there's a
whole lot of pride there from the end of
high school until about the first year
in college so I I did not pick up a ROTC
and naval ROTC scholarship at Boulder
but you can enroll as a volunteer in
hopes of picking up a scholarship so I
joined the naval ROTC at University of
Colorado Boulder and shortly got kicked
out just for getting in trouble and I
remember the the battalion Midshipmen
commander pulled me in for my counseling
and said you will never become a Navy
SEAL and also at that time you wanted to
be in the seal to you I was going
between the seals and Force Recon and
you know lo and behold we had this guy
then I won't use his last name it was a
Force Recon marine fifth force at the
University of Colorado Boulder as a Mesa
marine enlisted to Michigan education
program marine it was just impressive
built like a little tank everything
about am articulate smart confident not
last guy in the room
and so he sort of took me under his
wings I had don't worry about it
College is not gonna work out for you
this girl
why don't you do what you want to do and
you know walk me down to the recruiting
office in Boulder Colorado signed up and
when I signed up I came back to Northern
California for a few months while I was
waiting for my my bootcamp date enjoyed
myself and then when it was time to go
you know I sort of dropped the last
minute information on my parents mom
having a father that was in the military
she accepted it pretty well and for my
father he was he was not happy given his
were you know everything is about our
perceptions in life in his perception
his experience with army was not a
favorable one and so he was livid and
you know we had a few words and he did
not see me off to the airport my brother
my mother did and then fast forward to
to Camp
Ben again had given me some good advice
like a you can turn this around in the
Marine Corps will give you every every
opportunity to do that and so I crushed
it and boot camp graduated honor man out
of like you know three hundred kids and
on graduation day or the day prior
you know the bands can come out and see
you and they line up the entire recruit
battalion and loaned the holder who's in
front
carrying the guide on me and that's the
one time you know me my father did not
get along in high school because again
not his fault you just see him doing
this and shaking his head and you ever
since that at that time my father and I
see each other in different light we
still clash because we were so alike but
out we you know we've got a common
understanding and he's just a good man
my parents are good folks like I
couldn't you know it was never want for
love for discipline in this royal
household was a great house it's weird
too because as
parent you're always thinking if you try
and impose too much on your kids you're
just gonna you're just gonna push them
in the other direction you know saying
so you know for like for instance your
dad could have been like no you're not
joining it and you would have been so
rebellious probably too joined anyway
isn't done you know then you would just
not got along even more but he had to
just be like okay I'm not gonna see you
off but I'll be there graduation dude
I'll put you this way I love the Marine
Corps best runs service albeit they're
the small service best run service in
the US military
you just can't debate that and I think
what he saw was he sent a boy off in
like within three months he saw ya at
the beginning of a man yeah and I mean
he loved it he took it on wholesale he
loved it so much that he would pass by a
recruiting office he'd stop get some
doughnuts and bring him into the office
and shake her hand I mean he loved the
military at this point he sought from a
different I mean we literally changed
his experience in Vietnam to a favorable
one yeah yeah the Marine Corps has
really just mastered that whole thing of
taking a recruit and turning him into a
Marine
they damned really good at that they are
really good it's awesome
the thing I always said about the Marine
Corps is there's you know in the SEAL
Teams you'll get these totally great
guys at the high end of the spectrum and
you'll get bat much worse guys at the
lower end the spectrum the Marine Corps
it just keeps it all in it's much
tighter group like you know what you're
getting it's gonna be it's gonna be a
marine and it's gonna be good to go
you're talking about like they're minute
of angle yeah yeah it's a night shot
group the single teams you know we get
some we get some awesome guys for sure
but then you get a couple scattered out
there a couple stray rounds it's better
off paper don't worry about that little
yeah jack so so then what year was this
now just like 1998 was it was 98 98 so
so glad I came in but before 9/11 cuz I
got to see the pre-war military and then
you know became what I call the the G
watt babies that were absolutely spoiled
in this sounds you know contradictory is
smelled by war yeah yeah yeah so what
what you do under would you what was
your mos so when in as a Jesus I'm even
forgetting it uh-oh 311 riflemen check
but so when I was at the school of
imagery these Recon Marines show up and
you can always tell the Recon Marines
they have the dual cool the you have to
double trouble
and the hair's a little longer and they
stand a little taller and so unbeknownst
to me they they literally had a tryout
that that day and so that was my
opportunity to get into recon early and
I did extremely well finished first
within that class and they're like okay
do you want to go recon I said yes
absolutely and so out of the school of
infantry when I graduated from there it
was straight to the base of constants
course right next to buds Wow in
Coronado for three months how many guys
I'll to go straight through that
pipeline like that so you do it abdomen
float usually you had to do some
infantry time before you try it out but
I think you know similar to the demands
of post 9/11 when we started the Green
Beret community started open and up the
18 X program for guys straight off the
street into the Special Forces recon
would occasionally do the same thing and
so very few and I just happen to hit at
an opportune time pass the screening and
I'll tell you what BRC was tough and I
have nothing but respect for those guys
let's see you know it's not they don't
have a hell week but it is it is man
town in every respect ya know I should
see this guy's obviously we see him all
the time calling through classes and
then so and then you show up where'd you
go where'd you go after that
so first we comment a lien I can't
Pendleton and it was able to quickly
thrown into schools it was awesome so
got dive school right off the bat which
is the marine combatant dive course in
Panama City Florida which was I'll tell
you what and most seals don't like to
hear this it was as tough as second
phase if not tougher and even
academically they dove in a lot deeper
to the dive physics met
and so you had guys getting dropped for
for academics and then after that it was
shortly after Sniper school which I was
ill-prepared for loved I remember my mom
I went back to San Francisco because I
had a weekend off tonight and you had to
build your own ghillie suits and I built
the worst ghillie suit that you probably
have ever seen I still have the thing in
storage it looks like Chewbacca lying on
the ground but past that school by the
skin of my teeth and I think we started
with 14 we graduated 12 and it literally
came down to the last stock and a guy
named Brian from Idaho who had been with
a stable attune mmm in the Marine Corps
which is more or less a sniper platoon
and literally helped me get in my last
position and sacrificed himself because
he didn't need to score perhaps grow now
run and in past but I made up for it in
that year the shooting yeah the shooting
was not a problem
it was just stalking since I had no real
preparatory work going and then those
guys ad it was stuff how was your
patience level during stalking was it
good it was you know it was decent the
problem was we we went to Sniper school
in January in California which is cold
and so we were out there all the time
sometimes rain and so you know the
patience was it was fine it was just the
pain of sitting there which he had to
contend with and then what and then you
go on deployment no so did a entire
workout and actually shifted over to
another platoon because I was at first
recon battalion and it was a company at
the time and we turned into a battalion
when I was there so I transferred from
seven platoon to a new platoon and
continued a workup and had a great
officer pulled me aside he's like hey
man I want to put you in for the me set
program which again is the marine
enlisted commissioning the education
program for the listeners that's where
they send an active-duty marine usually
a corporal sergeant or Staff Sergeant to
go back and get their college degree on
the marine cordon and then come back as
an officer
it's because you've shown some promise
what I say is I'd only been in two
alcohol-related incidents in the Marine
Corps and so they said hey I'm Joe but I
so did officer put me in I filled out
the package and got selected as a
corporal very early in my career and so
when they asked me what I wanted to go I
wanted to go to university of texas did
not get in cuz what's trackback they
look at high schoolers no in so believe
it or not at Bindu wedding in Austin
whatever one of my recon buddies and
loved the town and the same guy looked
at me he's like hey man why don't you
try Texas A&M he's like it's it's like
the next best thing it's only about an
hour and a half outside of Austin I'm
like okay all right and of course I'm a
corporal at the time I don't have the
money to go visit Texas Aenon internet
was not exactly booming at that time and
so I just submitted an application
actually some Marines that were there
called me and they made it sound like a
great place and so when I went out there
drove out there with my three boxes of
household goods and it is just a country
town with fifty thousand college
students and it was a great opportunity
but College Station was not for me and
the war had kicked off mm-hm and so I
finish school in three years and got out
of there and then how did you go from at
what point did you tell me you wanted to
join the Navy so I you know going out
there I had about a 75% had already made
my decision that I wanted to switch over
the seals even if you looked at it from
a time perspective had I gone to TBS and
then you know officer infantry course it
would have taken me the same amount of
time to get to a SEAL team mm-hmm and so
it just made common sense I had worked
with a few seals during the war cups in
your cups at first recon battalion you
know they were older statistically more
highly educated more physically fit in
the biggest part there
so gone and they had the money I was
still carrying it in 1682 as a recon
marine miss Nyberg yeah we just didn't
have the money we didn't have the gear
and so you never see seals switch from
the SEAL Teams to recon but you see a
lot of Recon Marines switch over to
SOCOM units they either go seal green
beret and a lot them with PG mm-hmm
which for the listeners is a Air Force
pararescue jumper so I did go to marine
OCS and I gotta tell you again that was
a challenge I lost I think I went in and
around probably 185 and lost about 20
pounds that it didn't need to to lose he
said that was a summer in Quantico and I
was impressed and you talk about
maintaining that standard that quality
spread that the Marine Corps does so
well especially within their officer
ranks that's the reason yeah yeah how
long is how long is marine corps post
yes three months and how did if you if
you knew you wanted to go in the Navy
how come they sent you to Marine Corps
yes so the me set program you actually
go to OCS after the or during the first
summer afternoon got it you still come
back as a sergeant it was a sergeant in
that time I continued toward your degree
and once you finish a degree then you
get commissioned one year prior and
here's the fun thing so one year prior
to graduating they said hey when to my
Marine officer instructor who's a major
here's a prior enlisted guy himself
great guy I'm okay I think about your
skills he's like okay let's put it back
again I was like hey the military's
gonna get their pound of flesh to me
either way do what you want to do the
commanding officer was Marine colonel
did not see it that way that was just so
during the process of the injury to the
Corps pretty much I know they'd really
hate you the major prep knew yet he's
like hey just listen to what he has to
say
nod your head and just step out of the
room I gotcha yeah and so the inner
surface transfer was almost immediately
improved it was the day was that easy of
a process but then they told me I needed
to attend something called out in many
buds mmm that summer of my junior year
and so when I show up you have about 35
Midshipmen from naval ROTC units the
Naval Academy and then one sergeant in
his Marine Charley's and it is you know
khakis a khaki top with blue bottoms
with a red stripe and I'm amongst 34
guys in white you know I just stuck out
and it was gone II highway course yeah I
was still very much a sergeant so they
did love me towards the end because like
they said hey we need this done I would
step up you know hey fellas let's get
this done and the guys sort of rally
around me and I'd you know don't behold
at the end of that I had a spot waiting
for me when I graduated and it didn't
hurt that uh the the CEO of buds was a
former Marine himself oh yeah yeah
that's that's awesome
it's a good way to get that in there the
prior Marines that come into teams are
always got a little extra squared away
nests inside them put in their brain and
buds any factor of buds
does anyone could say it's not it's a
non fact a non factor what was the
biggest factor you had patience
it was patient so I asked you about
patience in Sniper school what were you
in fascia with so you in Sniper school I
was still new guy oh yeah that's right
so you stepping into a community that I
highly admired that I want to be a part
of was the easy part it was some of the
instructors had a very they were very
artistic and getting under your skin
and so here's it now subsets not when is
it most oh yeah Oh Thrissur oh it's it's
game time and in fact I think you you
you were deployed right around that time
yeah well I was deployed in 2003-2004 my
first deployment to Iraq yeah cuz your
counterpart your sister platoon
commander visited me okay in buds Konya
it was right before you guys went all
right on and which I have a funny story
about a jati when you came to speak to
us
so you know just the the patients are
going through the process you and you
went through John see you did okay hmm I
did not remember that that's weird so
you you had you a little bit impatient
of going through buds like basically
you're saying oh man I'm ready to get in
the game and they're like okay take this
sweep this grinder and do all this dumb
stuff that you have to do yeah a hundred
percent yeah it's when people ask
because people ask me all the time hey
I'm 33 years old I want to go in the
military do you think it's a good idea
I'm always like here's the problem the
problem is you're 34 years old there's
some real benefits that in that you're
mature and you are smart and you have
knowledge about the world here's the bad
part you're mature you're smart you have
knows about the world because when
they're like hey we want you to do this
completely ridiculous task that makes no
sense whatsoever
you're not gonna feel like doing it and
you're gonna have to do it and that's
gonna grade on you even more when I was
18 years old and I joined the Navy it
literally didn't matter what they made
me do
I would like well I get what you just
said when you when you join the Marine
Corps and when when Ben said do you hey
look you can you just just do what they
tell you to do and life's gonna be good
you like I I didn't no one told me that
boy and I got to boot camp I was like oh
I do what they tell me to do in life is
gonna be good that's what's gonna happen
so like all my underwear
whatever clean the toilets hey let's do
this and that's a lot easier when you're
18 that knows when you're 34 a lot
easier it is and you know it's not so
much what they tell you to do they tell
you what to do but they want to see if
you perform it's not that we're trying
to create robots and you know a lot of
people you have to demystify that about
the military but buds is just a long
process and then while we're going
through it they're telling us stories
about what you guys are doing overseas
or you know we had one seal passed away
in Afghanistan that time someone
received a Navy Cross in front of us in
the whole time you want to be those guys
not the medals or any of that but you
want to be the gladiator in the arena
and you know you have 12 more months of
training before you can even show up 2-0
to the other the other big thing and you
knew this cuz you've been the rink the
other big thing that people don't
understand is the fear that we all had
that this thing was gonna end
we weren't gonna do anything that was
the biggest fear I had was this Wars
gonna happen it's gonna be over in three
months and I won't have deployed and
I'll have to do the rest of my Navy
career never have gone ever going into
combat which was the biggest nightmare I
can imagine total nightmare
dad that would have been it's the same
for the guys that were in the Gulf War
yeah that certain platoons got to go
over there yeah and they sat behind
thinking they were gonna backfill him
and the war was gonna be a long war and
then it's over in what six days yeah I
had a Master Chief friend that was on
the last plane to be the last platoon
going to Vietnam and the and the plane
got shot down they didn't go so I can do
total nightmare for them but it's hard
for people to understand that mentality
of how bad you want to go and it's just
the way it is man I wish there was some
nice thing to say about it or some
psychological way to explain it away
like hey it's just no it's like I'm just
gonna say the way it is when you're
young and you're in the military you
want to go to war that's all there is to
it I'm sorry I that's the way it is but
you believe you believe in what you are
doing there's a sense of purpose and
again it is counterintuitive that anyone
would want to go to combat I'm super
stoked that you feel that way I'm gonna
here to tell you and MIT to you that
like I just wanted to go to war I just
wanted to go to war I actually another
old Vietnam guy he when he left SEAL
team one he goes he goes I joined the
Navy in 1970 so I could kill people for
my country and I was like oh yeah I know
what he's talking about good you know
the funny thing is you start to love it
you start to love oh oh yeah you know
that's not a bad thing you funny enough
I took a job went right when I retired
at Texas A&M System was the director of
veteran services for all 12 campuses but
there's this sort of old hen that uh a
mother hen that dude I just didn't
really like me you know she leans in
she's like what is the worst part about
war and I look at her and say that it
has to end just walked right up and you
could hear that
it's the classic line that they got
right in Apocalypse Now is when Colonel
Kilgore's like he just he's distraught
he's talking about napalm in the morning
and that smell that gasoline smell the
whole hill smelled like victory and
someday this war is gonna end and that's
the worst thing he can think of cuz hey
man he's a battalion commander of a
cavalry unit in Vietnam he's got he's on
top of the world he's on top of the
world there's nothing more important in
the world to him ever
he can't even imagine it and he's
depressed that some day the war is gonna
end yeah so so we're worried so you get
done with buds buds the biggest thing
you people always ask about the physical
part of buds you're in good shape no
factor yeah yes is it physically
exhausting of course what do you wanna
be tired you know what it is also is uh
it's an it's an opportunity actually
starts cementing your reputation yeah
and again I was very much still sergeant
and the instructors love me because I
would rally the boys even you know what
I like to call a healthy appetite or
healthy disrespect for authority there
is to get the guys fired up against the
effort and they didn't pay a little bit
you know you seem smoking all right so
it again you know get the fire in the
gut the boys love me they ride around me
an officer you got to fire the gun yeah
I haven't heard that too much have you
heard that too much you know I don't
know I haven't heard that too much I a
caveat or what is it called I don't
forget what it's called but I had to one
of my buddies text me today oh you're
making it sound like buds is super easy
it's not easy and I was like no no no no
let me let me correct myself
I'm not saying buds is easy like you
said buds is hard it's it's physically
hard the hardest thing to me I think
physically is that it goes on day after
day after day after day after day and so
when you're doing a four mile time run
which should be pretty easy because in
first phase you've got 32 minutes to do
that that's a long that's a slow pace
even for a grown man that's a slow pace
even for a big guy that's a slow pace
but when you've done whatever 8008 count
bodybuilders the day before and then you
got up at 3:00 in the morning and you
did for eight million flutter kicks and
then you go out get on the
and you do a timed run in soft sand with
boots on it's not easy and that's what
that's what trips people up
I think the grind you the one thing -
for me that was that was a driver is uh
there was no way that I was gonna
disrespect the marine reconnaissance
community no way there are some warriors
I mean there's a lot of warriors within
that community and so that was always
over my head no way was I don't know
that would just be a complete you a
complete utter lack of respect for the
Canadian from the quitting and buds is
really hard to understand and I I had
like a I had like a midlife crisis
several months ago about because some
people that I knew about and that I've
talked to had quit and and like I didn't
get it and and there's been guys from
the Marine Corps that have gone through
that I've been like oh that's awesome
and then they can't you're you're
thinking yourself how does this even
happen so I'm a hundred percent on board
with the thought that no one knows who's
gonna make it through no one knows like
you can't say this guy's gonna make it
he's a stud or this person is not gonna
make it because they're weak you you
literally don't know now could i bat
sixty percent maybe seventy percent
maybe but there's no way you could make
a sure thing there's not one person in
the world that you could say this guy is
going to make it through buds a hundred
percent there's no person in the world
you can say that about that I think that
I know of the most humbling lesson I
learned in buds and you can find this
funny was I went through buds with a guy
named Ryan job sound familiar
and again remember I'm so really fired
up Marine Sergeant that just pinned on
bars and from judging a book by it's
cover you look around you're like you're
not gonna make it everything was sloppy
about him and I even told him no one
point of oh hey man
you're not gonna make it you should quit
now and just to watch him and the
instructors zeroed in on him and the kid
had no quit and even at the henna hell
week having been
be more than anyone in that class the
instructors actually pulled him aside
and they said hey you're good to go but
we've thrown everything at you in the
kitchen sink and you stood strong he's
gonna be a great seal and I watched that
in the mic oh man I am I to judge who's
gonna make it news not and that was a
that was a life lesson I still remember
it wasn't until Ramadi that I apologized
to Ryan he sort of giggling a second
yeah I know it's like you all thought I
wasn't gonna make it yeah like you said
though no zero quit zero quit and and
doesn't matter what you do to me I'm
gonna beast right here so then you get
done you get done with buds so I came
and talked to your John C class what I
talked to you guys about you said you
you and your task unit commander okay I
came and talked about the deployment is
okay awesome but there's a Nero it's on
the second act the classroom for junior
officer training course which I
eventually took over from for life later
on there's a narrow passageway and just
asking the commander for Jocko and Jocko
coming off as Pettine commitment or had
this we're standing like this and they
created a little lane and as each of us
walked through Jocko would lean in and
basically make you shimmy through right
buzz I like screw this guy now you wants
to listen to you and I mean naturally a
he's a physically intimidating dude but
like you really like that guy man I'm
sorry bro I was fun with new guys though
it didn't stop there and we'll and then
he showed up you went right to T you
went you go right to team 3 after that I
did showed up in November of 2004 and
there was three slots open for Gio's
immediately and they went to all Naval
Academy guys and I got stuck in hops
working with a great guy right now that
we both know and I absolutely looked out
for me and so
sent me to free fall right away and then
when I finished that up he's like hey do
you want to go join the boys overseas
because team three was deployed the time
I'm like yeah so was you surely after
December found myself on a plane and
arrived in Baghdad and ballin I was
finally in the game I was there that's
half the battle and I loved it yeah and
then what were you doing just tagging
along with the boys so yes they give you
some strange job description but it just
meant hang out and wait to go on all
this so working in the the job naturally
as an assistant operations officer but
there was another SEAL team that was
there remember they were do do they
would longside SEAL team 3 and fell in
with the platoon commander quickly and
he's like hey jump on the Humvees you're
a 50 Cal gunner you know when we go out
just watch us do our thing you know set
up a cordon with the vehicles yeah and
slowly learn and so every time they
would go out I would jump into the
Humvee as a 50 Cal gunner and I was in
heaven yeah I was an absolutely that get
any better than just freaking stoked
yeah and then you came back so you come
home from that deployment and then you
get put into B is that is it the did you
get a platoon the next time were you
like did you get stuck being ops again
in that task unit so I get yeah I got
stuck this is like good deals for good
seals yeah
I got stuck it has tu Charlie op so Oh
get some and so again the other slots
were full I'd have to wait for an AIC it
would mean I still get to deploy I
actually it's a double benefit when you
look at at the end of the day I actually
get two deployments those guys after
they're done with their assistant
platoon commander board step I have to
go elsewhere
and so it actually was a blessing in
disguise and then okay so you're in that
task unit and interestingly that task
unit is in the book extreme ownership in
a very short passage and I was looking
at it to think about what what we said
about it but there was a task unit at
SEAL team 3 at the time and the task
unit commander and one of the platoon
commanders they didn't get along they
had issues with each other
and they couldn't they couldn't get they
couldn't put it aside they just couldn't
put it aside and even the commanding
officer again this is in the book and
the commanding officer said hey look
I'll tell you what I know you two have
issues because they had both come to him
separately and I'm probably screwing up
the story but it was something like this
they both came to him and said hey look
I can't work with this guy in the other
classes I can't work with this guy and
he brings them together and says look
it's Friday by Monday come in here and
tell me how are you two are gonna work
together understand and they're like
yeah I got it sir they come in Monday
and what do they say I can't work with
him I can't work with him and he goes
okay you guys can't work together guess
what you're fired and he fired both of
them which was a which was a great move
actually I bet I think it was a good
move you know if you've got two people
that can't figure out how to work
together under the threat of being fired
from your job that's a real problem
especially if you can't substantiate it
I mean if you can't go in there and say
listen here's the reasons why I can't
work with this guy it's this this and
this because obviously I had the
opportunity to do that and there's
situations where you say look I can't
work with this guy his immoral or he's
unethical or he treats everyone horribly
and I can't sit there and watch this
happen like there's reasonable arguments
that you could make where you literally
can't work with someone but when you
can't even substantiate an argument as
to why you can't work with someone and
then you get told okay I get it
and I don't hear any real reasons so you
two go figure it out and you come back
and say no ken it's not happening it
seems to me like a good move is okay
neither one of these guys I trusted go
overseas and form relationships with
other military units and foreign
military units and do their job properly
and he fired him both you somehow they
said okay you know what collateral
damage we're gonna take Sorelli we're
gonna move him into task unit bruiser
that's what they did and I was stoked
because I wanted more people always you
know because you get another 50 Cal
gunner you get another officer you get
another shooter you get it's another
person it's awesome and I was stoked to
have you coming on board and it was
there was like a little bit of joy I
mean there was there was drama because
you know inside inside bruiser was like
no drama like we don't we don't play
drama like we solve problems we keep our
mouths shut we do what we're supposed to
do we if we got problems we figure them
out we straighten them out and we move
on and we could see all this
drama unfolding in that other task unit
which is is not cool I mean you don't
like seeing that at a SEAL team you want
the whole SEAL team to be kick-ass and
so you see if task unit that's in
turmoil it's like not fun to watch
especially cuz I knew I'd basically know
every player in there I knew every one
of those guys and you watch them just
falling apart
and eagles are flaring up and it's just
a nightmare man it was a nightmare
anyways you get bit basically out of
that whole catastrophe that out comes
Mike Cirelli and it's asked me to
bruiser and the best worse deal I've
ever been best worst deal I've ever been
dealt so you check in and I remember I I
was thinking to myself okay I didn't
know you I've looked at your record I
knew you were in the Marine Corps I like
I knew that you're gonna be squared away
that was my that was my as much as you
can predict you know I was thinking okay
this guy was in the Marine Corps this
guy's gonna be awesome you seemed like
you were serious and you want to do a
good job and and so I was my assumption
was you're gonna kick ass
however I had to be a little bit you
know I had to do a little precautionary
precaution to take some precautionary
measures to make sure that you
understood where I was coming from you
know I wanted to make sure you knew
where I was coming from while I having a
little fun with me just a little just a
smidge yeah so that's why that's why
we're so introducing you into the test
bringing you in I wanted to let you know
like hey this is we're on that you know
we don't have any job later that's why
so that's why we did the whole the old
briefing so in the mechanical so in the
mechanical room so at SEAL team 3 at the
time there was no ceilings in any they
were doing this big remodel and there
was no ceilings in any of the platoon
spaces or taskinen spaces there was all
just there was a wall with no ceiling so
you could hear everything that was being
said and so whenever I had something
legitimate like an issue to bring up
with someone and it was almost it was
out in fact it wasn't even almost always
it was always my my jail it was either
Lafe or Seth or one of the other Jos and
I'd bring him in there and I'd be like
hey here's what's going on cuz in the
mechanical room there's like a loud
noise and no one can hear you and that's
the only one that still had a ceiling
for privacy for privacy was like the
cone of silence
yeah the cone of silence so whatever
someone was doing something that I
really need to tighten up
was getting out of line and I really
needed to talk to him on on the secret
level and by secret I mean I didn't want
anyone gossiping about when I was about
to say so I'd bring them in the
mechanical room and and tell him what
was up and so that's what I that's how I
welcome to Mike into the task unit go
ahead so have you come out of an
incident where I was wrapped up in a
little bit of drama and beat shifted
that incident though you were just sort
of like in that group or were you you
know so since I was close the operations
officer which is basically the the guy
that handles the day-to-day affairs the
troop commander I was naturally close to
him and if you want to step back to that
task unit because it was one of the
again many great leadership lessons
across the course of my career for a new
guy watching that in the SEAL Teams it
was a you know I was questioning
maybe this community is not for me if
this is the norm because that this is my
first experience so this means this is
normal to me
it just seemed like backstabbing and
egos one of the platoons they performed
and they stayed out of the drama for the
most part between the spittoon commander
in the in the task unit commander it was
from day one it was just like watching a
train
derail you just saw it coming
in the fact that the boss laid down the
rule and they come back on Monday
morning and paint him into a corner I
don't know what they expected yeah and
they both got fired and it both affected
their career but he was you know I
actually I can say as a new guy it was a
great thing to see in retrospect and
because you learned what not to do yeah
but when I was told to report in to
Jocko you know I'm not in the best of
spirits sir and knocking the door to
task unit bruiser and say hey Mike's
really Jocko uh-huh report in and he
said Roger come with me and he had a
sheet of paper in his hand principal's
office
yeah I'm like what's going on in until I
follow him into everyone knows what the
mechanical room is but nobody goes in
and I mean you just want to picture like
cogs turning yeah yeah Wow there's a
steam coming out Nightmare on Elm Street
that's our Freddie yeah you actually
told me to pop too and things so I
popped too and you basically lay down
the law of hey I heard what happens you
have clean slate here but do not bring
drama into my task unit here's your
counseling sheet you've been formally
counseled and pretty much left the room
and I think I sat in the room and I'm
just staring the wall like what my
career in the SEAL Teams is gonna be
extremely sure I'm getting it from all
directions and what he did was you lay
down the law and I understood there was
just one thing to do at that point and
that was just before yeah it was
performing yeah the other backstory here
is is that the platoon that you're
talking about that perform well inside
that task unit the platoon chief and
that because he was he was one of my
good friends from way back and because
there's all this stray voltage going
around about whose fault this was and he
came up to me and he goes hey you're
getting Sorelli and I was like yeah he
was he's fuckin good to go and I was
like check and that's like literally all
I needed to hear cuz when he told me
that I knew like he's like I respect his
opinion and so I actually knew you were
gonna be good to go a little bit
stronger than I did I gave no no no he
was in terms of first people he meet in
the SEAL Teams was absolutely welcoming
to every new guy no hazing whatsoever
you can perform as a new guy you're a
part of this platoon you have a voice
and once he found out because you
snapper found out uh I was a sniper in
the Marine Corps he's like oh yeah hey
I'm making a call the army right now go
check out a suite of guns and I was
shocked and you know I trained up as a
sniper as an officer for the entire
worked up and it was because of that one
guy who welcomed me with open arms and
you know despite his long history in the
teams I mean no ego whatsoever awesome
sorry so you given him that paper the
formal counseling that's like isn't that
something you normally do if you get in
trouble so much
to make a straight-up impression like
hey Aaron oh by the way I probably wrote
in my entire naval career less than five
I might have written three maybe so he
didn't even do anything yeah I know I
know I had to give one to life one time
like my my life Lafe did something and
the XO was like you need to write him up
and I was like definitely sir and so I
wrote him up in it and I shredded it
later or whatever you know it's like not
but there's a very few times that I
actually did that but again we were
getting you late it was pretty late we
were going on deployment soon and so it
was like okay let's let's get some you
gotta set the you know set the
expectations yeah there in the front you
know so we're not playing around and
then we go on deployment we go to Ramadi
we-well be guess before we did that we
did sir decks and all that kind of the
last little bit of training and then we
went on deployment to Ramadi no I did
not I joined you after surtax I
literally joined you three weeks before
we deploy hood God so I was that fresh
to ask you to bruiser no relationships
with a few guys that I got new uh two
buds with actually so remember mark lean
I transferred over the same yeah yeah
that was after sir Dex Wow are you sure
mark might have been before I was after
okay yeah I think mark was before yeah
yeah cuz oh that's right because the
everything fell apart insert X for you
guys but your surtax was before ours
that's right it was we've come back to
the Panama yeah that's when the
proverbial shit hit the fan with in that
basket and so then today we're getting
ready to go to Ramadi and what would you
you came he became what did you become
like like cuz I had a guy that was the
the tasking to ops
did I make you tasks you can assist in
office constantly demoted that was the
correct I was who I was a ops but
quickly became let me tell you something
this is a this is a great a great point
cuz all that like basically you know
what that is really it's like a test
like hey I'm gonna write you up let's
see what your attitude is you're
you know what his attitude was like
Roger I'm no drama don't worry about it
then it's like okay you're gonna work
for this other guy that's probably lower
and rank than you that has been in the
military for a year and you're gonna
work for him how do you how do you take
that ain't no Mike's attitudes like
Roger that I'm here to work those things
like when you when those things happen
because people ask me there's not that
kind of question all the time well you
know someone else got promoted or
someone else got this it's like what do
you do oh you work hard that's right and
that's exactly what you did and you know
it took a matter of days before I was
thinking okay he's all given a little
bit more I'll give a little bit more him
a little bit more and then very shortly
thereafter it's like look I guess what
you are ops now which it's not like this
huge great job but it's it's it's pretty
significant once we're on the ground in
Ramadi there's a lot of responsibility
there you had to count on you for a lot
of stuff and because you were freaking
squared away
and we're like okay Roger that no
attitude no never did you like I gave
you and then we got overseas I remember
I gave you the worst job which was I
sent you to the T G right so the T G for
those of you that don't know too much
about the military there's a there's a
headquarters above the task unit which
is called it's the SEAL team but when
you're on deployment it's called a task
group and they have all kinds of
administrative stuff that they got a
handle and we had a great team with
great support from our head shed but
they needed people to work they need
people to drive paperwork is basically
what they needed and so they needed an
officer to go over there for 30 days for
30 days and get you know work do all
this paperwork and I had to submit an
officer and I sent you and there's two
reasons why I did it well number one the
number one reason why I did it was
because I knew that you'd get there and
figure things out and help us grease the
skids for everything that we were doing
whereas if I send someone else their
money to be able to pull out off as well
and to because I knew when I get you
back I could do something awesome with
you like get you in the field which is
what I did
so yeah if you're in those situations
where you feel like you're you deserve
better you know just be quiet suck it up
do a good job and if you're the other
part that people get paranoid about is
they think well they won't notice
me yeah they think I should tell Jocko
how awesome I am
I should tell Jocko that I was in the
Marine Corps I should tell Jocko that I
I'm a sniper I should like hey I got a
better idea how about you just be humble
and just work and if you do that then
jock was this oh hey man let's guys
scored away I wonder why swear to I
could record oh he's in the Marine Corps
oh let me look at his record oh he's a
he's a sniper oh he was in recon okay
I've got a pipe hitter here cool I can
use him and he's humble on top of all
that as opposed to hey look at me cuz
believe me there's plenty of people that
come in and they want to bow up and act
like they're the baddest guy on the
planet it's like that's a real problem
that's a real problem because they have
a big ego it was to the point where I I
knew I'd burn my personal capital and so
it was time to rebuild and even before
he sent me the disaster
you know running ops quickly came
apparent that the other guy that was
ahead of me just wasn't gonna cut the
bill but uh leaf had asked me if I
wanted to go out and I'm like yeah I'm
in everything in me wanted to go out on
a mission with them because these guys
are already starting to kill you know a
lot of combatants but I had work to do
in terms of ops that Jaco had passed
down and I knew if I went out they
wouldn't gotten done and you wouldn't
let me made that call you would let me
yell but I you know I passed and Lafe
you know we were talking about that
yesterday I was late from the Texas and
he's like I remember that one thing and
we knew that was a sign that you were
gonna get your stuff done and he
actually made the right call and I know
what you were doing you were looking out
for the task unit instead of looking out
for yourself that's what that is you
were looking out for the task unit
instead of looking out for yourself you
were taking care of what your actual job
was instead of taking care of yourself
and that's again for everyone that's
wondering like how to act that's how you
act you take care of the team before you
take care yourself you stay humble you
don't think that you deserve more than
you're gonna get when you get handed a
shit sandwich
take a bite chew it put a smile on your
face and ask for another one and make
that one squared away too and that's how
that's how you're gonna get where you
want to go which for you eventually
meant going to join Delta platoon
awesome best experience I've ever had
and again with a app' tune that is
humble
if there is a personification of that
that is JP Danelle and those guys
welcomed me with open arms and I was
taken back by the by the humility
they're just they're sort of like you
know the way I described opportunities
they were like the little guy
they were the little guy in tasking and
bruiser in the sense that were just
quiet with what they did it's just
different personalities between Charlie
and Delta and you love both platoons but
they had a very different style of
leadership and you know I can't name any
of their names because Muslim are still
in active duty but it felt like home and
then being with Seth was educational
given the experience they had gotten
within those like two months that wasn't
there two and a half three months and
you know there was a steep learning
curve after three months called after
them and I'm stepping in is I had to
like speed up to the basically the speed
of war because they were already there
yeah they they had enough experience at
that point I mean it was it was an
insane amount of experience the-the-the
at first at one point they did 24
straight patrols into the Milaap and got
contacted every single time and then one
they didn't get contacted they were like
way up in the northeast section they
didn't get contacted and then the next
time they went out which was the day
later they will rule right back in it
again so the amount of experience that
they had was just was was ridiculous it
was ridiculous I remember saw I was
briefing the CG soda and I've made that
quote right there and I was like these
guys have been in contact on their last
23 their last 23 operations and the the
talk watch officer comes walking in and
she's like sir I was like yes and he
goes I just want to let you know debt
Cragar doors in a in a tick right now
and I was like Roger that and I looked
at the colonel said make that 24
yeah that was uh that was that was
pretty awesome we used to when those big
bigwigs would come to visit us in Ramadi
we would we would we would attempt to
make it all nice but what that looked
like was so obviously wretched that like
we would we would say hey you know if
we've got we'd lay out the MRE coffee
for them so like hey if you want a cup
of coffee use the MRE coffee we and we
make it like we were doing our best to
give him like the best treatment but
like the treatment that you're gonna get
just sucks cuz we're out here in the
middle and their supply chains not as
good as it could be and pay if you want
hey we really want you have coffee if
you have it so here's some Emory coffee
you can mix it up here get some and then
when they've left we cleared out the a
supply closet and put the coffee
machines back up yeah the funny thing is
you talked about the task group and
during my time there is for those big
wages that come in it was such a
deviation from what soft was doing in
Iraq prior to that and you know I like
to you know use Colonel MacFarland who
you need to have on this show yeah the
laws well he's retired now Lieutenant
General the former commander of the
one:1 Brigade Combat Team is that he
realized we weren't winning we are not
winning and to continue operations as we
have been doing is the wrong call and
things need to change and even at the
task group loved the commander over us
because it was a deviation from what
every other SEAL team had done you could
see him struggling whether it was the
right call and I remember a few times he
called me in to ask my opinion about
what was going on but he wasn't really
looking for an answer he was using me
just as a springboard for his own
thought process until I would talk very
little and he would just sort of keep on
talking and I mean he had a very solid
sort of thought process along the lines
of how he justified it and ultimately
you know he looked out for you and the
rest of the task units yeah and they
allowed us to look out for all the
conventional forces that we were working
exactly the 1:1 ad in the first the 506
and the 137 and three eight Marines and
all those guys that were on the ground
with us there who we were able to help
out as much as as much as possible only
because we got clearance to do those
operations which as you said was a was
outside the norm outside the norm
daytime operations staying out in the
city
supporting conventional forces at which
freaks some people out like why would
you be supporting them they should be
supporting you it's like well no no
they've got whenever a thousand soldiers
and they're taking down a giant part of
the city and we can help protect them so
we are a supporting element but it's
gonna be it's gonna have big impact so
it was uh it was awesome so when you got
when you got out to Corregidor with the
first to 506 how awesome is first the
500 how awesome is first the vile is
next the first of the 506 from the top
down we're a hardcore warriors yeah some
of the strongest leadership so now Major
General Romick I'm sorry Ron Clark was
the battalion commander at the time to
Lieutenant Colonel Dave Wommack I mean
I've never seen in my 20 years a
stronger soft conventional force
relationship other than Ramadi I mean it
was a textbook case of unity of effort
nobody worked for the other but they all
worked in unity towards the same end
state it was before India Ron Clark of
course you know Seth and all the boys
had set that relationship up they had
done a wonderful job and the fact that
you know I got out there before he
bestowed the first of the 506 Spade on
them and he you know I was there when he
got bestowed upon us it just I mean yeah
I need to qualify this you know getting
the Trident was one of the biggest
things one of the biggest
accomplishments my life but it was just
like a different sense of pride that
almost rates out there that this badass
lieutenant colonel that had been you
know in the sock for so long bestowed a
infamous you know symbol on our
shoulders and
you wear this in combat that was I mean
they did there's very few words to
describe how that felt I was um like he
said the relationship between the
between everyone between us between
everyone at the 1:1 ad it was just
freaking awesome
and I don't know if we'll ever be able
to capture that and describe it but man
it was it was awesome and and what they
did for us and we did whatever we could
for them and what they did for us man
was just the the sacrifices that they
made and and the effort that they put
forth to support what we were doing it
was it was it was awesome it was just
awesome
talk about just give like hey this is
what we were doing so people can hear
from your perspective like again you
know you don't need to get into tactics
that but just hey just a general this is
what we were doing we were covering and
moving with the first two five or six
that's how I put it we were recovering
and moving again all in this in pursuit
of the same goal it's win Ramadi and we
could have stuck with the status quo
with the nightly direct action rates but
it just had little impact compared to
what the the conventionals were doing
and they were gonna go out so we really
utilize the skill set that was unique to
the SEAL Teams and that was the sniper
overwatch and you know those positions
the sniper positions because we would
again we defied sort of traditional
tactics of those two to four guys that
went out maybe six guys in a sniper hide
and we went out in force fighting
positions fighting positions because
shortly you know after the first few
kills from our snipers it quickly turned
into a battle position because they can
sort of triangulate where you're at
based off the bodies lying on the ground
and they had become very good at it but
we would move out ahead of the front
line trace of the 5:06 setup sniper
overwatch mutually supporting sniper
overwatch to really protect me
conventionals doing major clearances
throughout from the lob district and it
was highly successful yes they did mean
we operated during the days sometimes it
did most often we would infiltrate at
night
prior to you know you use the advantage
of night to you into your unit set up
prior to the the confessionals coming in
the early morning and starting the the
clearance operations and then we pull
out during the day or stay until night
just to give ourself you know mitigate
risk is best possible but you you cannot
argue the numbers don't lie you cannot
argue with the numbers that the see acts
were going down enemy combatants were
you know killed were we're stacking up
and slowly you know take him one bite at
a time of that elephant we moved further
and further into central Ramadi which
was enemy-held territory up until 2006
and then from the other side Charlie
platoon was coming in from the from the
western side of Ramadi and it was like
eventually we just saw many men at a
little and called it good so when you
got over to Corregidor I mean obviously
you're working for stoner when you first
show up there how was that
stoners great I stoner is a very I don't
know the word eclectic is is a good way
to describe him so for the audience I
mean says stone is a Naval Academy
graduate highly intelligent you know the
guy almost had a photographic memory
ended up you know getting his on his
masters from Kristin
so clearly the guys intelligent what are
you saying about six-two six-three
yeah he was a he was a big dude he was
overly aggressive sort of had some extra
tissue above his uh his eyebrows it sort
of made him look like a caveman
but stoner had a reputation of of being
you know just that aggressive and that's
what was needed in that position but he
wasn't reckless and let me say that he
was he was very methodical and diligent
about most of the decisions he made and
you know for any leader that the burden
of command is he's a lonely place your
dash cam commander you know even though
you're close with Lafe and Jocko
and Seth you're also alone
and for Seth out there all by himself
because you know Andrew taken off used
by himself and you really had nobody
want to commensurate and so I think when
I get out there you know he was relieved
to have a an officer that was a little
more aggressive and confided it means so
I went everywhere with Seth every
meeting for the first of the 506 I think
he was in a sense relieved you know one
of my strengths and it sucks to say this
was I was actually a very good planner a
very good planner you know I took a lot
of pride in the fact that it was a
sniper and so I could do a lot of
analysis mission analysis don't in
mitigate risk and then I was very good
at knocking out the products almost to
my own demise and I'll get to that funny
story but uh Seth knew he could rely on
me for the little things to get that
done to clear the way for him to focus
on the more strategic picture would in
he had the battle of money and so yeah
because I respected him for what he had
done up to that point like very much in
a sense as a young seal I was trying to
earn his respect as well and I think I
did that towards the end because he knew
he can rely on me and I think quickly
out in the field I proved my worth to
remember him an officer with a sniper
rifle now and so finally in the game as
well but we grew extremely extremely
close to the point where he started to
bounce off you know bounce matters off
me for my opinion before he weighed
weighed in with some final decisions
and he became a brother quite frankly
and you know when the deployment was
over you know led the way and making
sure that he was sent off out of Delta
platoon and in a fine fashion you know
we got enough for getting the pistol but
it was a it was a nice pistol there's
like a 2,000 dollar pistol right the
boys were happy to chip in so we made
sure that we said Seth off with as much
love as he showed the the boys in let me
finish through you know with Seth in
that regard he loved loved the guys he
would hold them accountable by all means
you know he was close with guys but he
did not get in the way of him making a
decision
a right decision not what was best for
the guys but what was right for the guys
and he would make those hard decisions
and he didn't mind being unpopular if he
didn't yeah I at some point I'll be
talking a lot about him not now so now
we're almost done with deployment and
you guys had a matter of I don't know
what to call it in terms of number of
missions left might be zero might be one
might be two but it was almost time for
everyone to start packing up and and
heading home and that didn't mean that
the first of five or six was going home
because they weren't didn't mean the one
one eighty was going home because they
weren't didn't mean that they were gonna
stop doing it operations because they
weren't it didn't mean that the enemy
wasn't gonna stop trying to kill
Americans and so that meant that we
couldn't stop doing what we had to do
until the next SEAL team came in to
relieve us and take our place so there
was no there was no stopping there was
no stopping until it was time to go home
close as we were and I remember
consciously I said to myself I'm not
gonna say hey this day we'll do our last
mission because I think that's like call
me superstitious but that to me is like
a bad luck thing like hey okay guys this
is the last mission and even in my own
mind I said okay well we'll see how this
one goes and if another mission comes up
and so I never said to myself okay this
day or this something we're gonna stop
and I just knew that at some point we'd
have enough of the of the new group over
the new team would be here and we could
say I could say okay you know what we're
good now and we're going home
and I didn't want to make that account I
didn't want to make that like a set date
you know or a set time or a set number
of missions I just said when when we're
ready to be relieved we'll stop and
we'll just stop and we'll pack up cuz I
don't want guys out in the field
thinking hey if I can just make it
through this because that's bad or I
don't want guys in the field thinking
this is the last one I got to do and I
don't want that or anyone's mind not
even mind and so I even tricked myself
and just said okay we're gonna keep
going until we've got enough strength
from the other team and then we'll just
stop that when that day comes so you
guys kept operating and everyone did
kept operating kept going and it was
still despite the significant impact
there'd been on the enemy the enemy was
still bringing it and they were starting
to get a little bit more desperate and
because we had really shut down a lot of
their movements and they were starting
to really try and strike back
significantly when they could so
basically almost every time that we went
out into into Ramadi it was on at this
point so September 29th 2006 you guys
were doing another another operation in
support of the first the 506 operation
Kentucky jumper in the heart of the mob
district right by the stadium we had
inserted the other night before again in
the area we had operated multiple times
before we knew it like the back of our
hand we had taken multiple positions in
that area and on this specific one we
had taken a very dominant building when
I say dominant in terms of high device
we had the height over any other
building and we were as diligent and
methodical
as we were with any other mission um and
shortly after sunrise we were engaged
with enemy first in the 506 had come in
to clear several sectors of the mob
district and I think by noon myself and
another SEAL sniper an aid for gas and
you two had it sort of laid down and get
some rest because we've been up for
close to 24 hours and Mikey and I were
holding the security and Mikey actually
jumped on my sniper rifle to get some
gun time and there was a seal to his
left 3 feet and that was 3 feet to his
right and of course one of the things as
a young guy and I realize now is I just
always pushed to the edge and sometimes
to take care of the guys you have to
take care of yourself and I just didn't
learn that early on so what I always try
to stay awake and I try to sleep as a
little as possible because I thought had
to be there you know in case they needed
me to make a decision in reality they
didn't need me there to make a decision
they had it and I was very replaceable
but when you're young you don't always
realize that and so I was in and out of
sleep you know Bobby sitting on the
ground like he was sitting in a chair
and Mikey and I were in conversation
basically about going home because we
knew that was one of the last missions
and Mikey was excited because he was
going to Sniper school I don't know if
you remember that you guys had lined
that up he'd been a machine gunner most
of the wall all the deployment located
right next to JP who was the point man
and so that was my keys job was to
overwatch like st. Michael overwatch JP
and guess they ran into enemy contact
they would be the first ones and Mikey
would lay it down and like he had laid
it down on multiple multiple occasions
before and then the other thing we were
talking about is he was dating a girl
and we were talking about that me he
knew I was excited because my daughter
at the time was 2 years old and you
I don't think I'd talk to my family much
on that deployment cuz we were just so
busy and that that's sort of my style
too is once I'm deployed is it was
easier for me not to talk to my family
because it was actually a distraction
because it would it would mess with my
mind
so you knew the mission was to get home
to your family as quickly as possible
and in the best way for me to do that
I'm not saying it was the right way was
to focus on what I needed to do and it
had 100% of my attention because I would
not you know for the life of me I would
not allow one of my guys to get killed
but unfortunately that's out of our
control it's war in wars not clean but
midday you know contact had died down
they were still moving it out there but
during the conversation a grenade had
come over the roof and again I was in
and out of sleep but what really sort of
snapped me to heart was racing right
away was my key snapped up remember he
was in a seat the grenade had come over
the roof and hit him in the chest
and bounced on the ground right in front
of him and now there's there's a lot of
accounts out there that are wrong I saw
some other seal speaking to a crowd
about this you know that there was a
entrance to the rooftop that you know a
stairwell that would go down in the main
main building and that wasn't true we
were actually like 15 meters from that
stairwell at the very edge of the roof
closest to the street when Mikey I say
Mikey had the greatest chance of getting
in a way is that all he had to do was
dive in the other direction and he
mostly I can take a little shrapnel to
the bottom of the feet into the gaps but
he would have gone home and the thing
that amazes me is you know I'm not the
dullest tool in the shed nor am I the
sharpest but the cognitive ability to
assess what just didn't happen and the
potential outcomes that if he chose
self-preservation which is not a long
haul that the seal to his left in myself
would it just ate in the grenade in the
it's completely just done and the other
seal to his left had kids as well
and you know you play this over in your
head
and trust me I play it every day and the
first thing I think about when I wake up
is this Mikey and my kids and the last
thing I think about when I go to sleep
it's Mikey my kids and the reason I say
that is there's a picture of Mikey on my
wall and you know it's that iconic
picture of Mikey with Seth and another
seal in the background with the yellow
smoke and he's carrying the the machine
gun and y'all grenade and then um he
dove down on it and not to add humor to
the situation but it's almost like that
scene from snatch where you know the
guys are frozen as uh the shotguns going
off and they say you sit there with a
stupid little interface yeah I probably
sat there with a stupid look on my face
because one we you know we're in the
heat midday we've been up for 24 hours
were exhausted and it just happened so
fast and Mike he just took action in a
matter of milliseconds I mean he
assessed the situation he knew the
outcomes and he made the most selfless
decision that anyone can ever make
there's no walking away from that and I
know there's there's some people that
have walked away from jumping on a
grenade but those those are statistical
anomalies and it went off and by him
smothering it it finalized the grenade
blast to the sides towards uh the seal
to his left to myself and we almost had
mere wounds like through and throughs in
in both legs and you know I'd never been
that close to an explosive we we are we
work with explosives all all the time
within the SEAL Teams but we were very
diligent about mitigating risk in the
Prem
that you have to be so far from the
explosives the thing actually picked me
up and flipped me over and I just I
could feel the pain you people talk
about if you're shot or wounded like you
don't feel it the adrenaline takes over
that ain't the case it was immediate
hot metal burning inside my legs or
through through wounds just bleeding so
at the time I didn't know if I had legs
I couldn't even I didn't even want to
look so I put my head in sort of
forehead on the dusty rooftop and just
took that big sort of bite ate the pain
and a third or fourth seal was already
moving towards our direction
he'd been affected by the blast as well
didn't take any scrap metal but it
rattled all of us and looked at Mikey
whose head was turned towards me and I
yelled Mikey Mikey and it was just
lifeless and so the next decision the
next thing that happens is we start to
get lit up by enemy machine-gun fire all
chaos it's breaking out it's pure chaos
pure pure hell the Iraqi soldiers on the
roof with us except for one who's close
to us but he was actually stricken and
fair in the fetal position they all ran
off the roof and left us so you've got
one critically mortally wounded two
someone out of the fight they can't
stand up and then the third is dealing
with with Mikey and so we were left
pretty much you could say left to die by
the Iraqi soldiers and so I immediately
went to my in bitter to to call for Seth
who was in a mutually supporting
overwatch position about 500 metres away
and the blast had knocked out my
inverter and so I'm calling finally you
know I pulled it in better out and it's
just clear screen and I turned it back
on reset it but the bitter has to go
through a it loads the program and it
takes
a minute let's say tops I didn't have a
minute and so still haven't looked at my
legs I'm looking around I see the Iraqi
soldier remember his name is Mohammed
actually spoke English and he's in the
field position I mean he's just stricken
Mifare and so I get up to run over to
him and as I stand up to run I just go
right down well literally on my face the
legs just wouldn't work and again sort
of the pain which glad to do give him
what Mike he's going through right now
and what are you doing did for us and I
crawl over there and the Iraqi soldiers
used Motorola's and SEF had Iraqis with
him as well and so I actually called out
to Seth Seth eventually got on that
Motorola and then I said worried at bad
Mikey's down hard we need you now and
they knew something was going on because
the fire is just you know hitting our
building but you as a commander you have
to wait you know you let the situation
phelp find out let your let your your
assistant platoon commander call back
and give you a sitrep of what's going on
he's probably hear on the radio trying
to find out but I got back to him
probably within a minute after the whole
grenade blast it had gone off in Seth
said hold on we're coming
and so I crawl back to where my keys at
the the four seals dragged him away from
the wall and then he's trying to work on
them and I told that guy Mike hey get on
the machine gun because remember Mikey
carries the machine gun nose right there
and he starts to lay down return fire
and it seemed like ages before Seth got
there but finally some Iraqi soldiers
had come out and they're starting to
return fire but you know it probably
only took Seth five minutes but you got
to remember Seth and all those guys were
set up within their position they
weren't ready to move so they had to
leave a lot of stuff behind they know
sometimes you're not wearing your your
kit because it's so hot you're there for
it was what a 48-hour operation you just
you're not always wearing a kit so they
have to throw in their kid probably and
get
and then when they move into the street
what happens the enemy ships fire under
fire and yeah you know we didn't have
our morphine kits and this was a problem
with sort of the process of how that
worked if you remember we had sent home
the guy who was side for him about a
week earlier and so I remember I finally
had the courage to look at my legs I
didn't expect to see anything there and
there was two two legs very bloody ACU
pants but they were there it have a sort
of a relief in a sense okay hey my legs
are there there's not working right now
and I went to grab for my morphine and
it was gone and so the other Steele and
I are you know we're pain but okay no
morphine on
Seth eventually gets there and they
start working on Mikey they didn't know
the building we're in and apparently
again gotta love the I think you
actually activated the Bradley's that
met us on the backside of the building a
completely different treated again there
was there was some confusion about where
to go and I did my best to clear that up
from what I remember which I don't
remember very well well they to the guys
from Seth's element grabbed me and I led
them through the stairwell down there
was an adjacent door to building behind
them in the back yard so we went through
that building to the road that was on
the other side a parallel road from the
road we were operating on it was a it
was a main road and they throw the other
wounded ceiling myself in there and then
the guy who was carrying Mikey brings my
key into the Bradley Fighting Vehicle
and we take off and that guy the look on
his face was pure exhaustion now within
the military we always you know we we
trained at the Buddy carry and we do it
as part of like physical training but
you're also rigid when you're carrying
your buddy and he's got his hand in your
back and Mikey was not a small boy yeah
easily probably to ten he's about
six-two six-three and this guy
I who carried him was I mean he's a
fiscal stunt and he was exhausted and we
talked about a years later because he
sort of put my key down in the Bradley
vehicle and he sat down just sort of was
exhausted in this out there and I yelled
it okay what are you doing you know
start CPR and he sort of snapped to and
started CPR you yeah actually came to me
here's late and he's like man I'm really
sorry about that I'm like brother you
don't have to apologize
you had just carried him you know
probably a hundred meters with combat
equipment on and you just you know you
weren't with it you took a second to
recover that it's not your fault but
everyone finds fault in that day and
everyone feels bad JP who should have
been there but had cut his finger if you
remember yeah wasn't there and yeah it
was you know you talk about the
relationship with the 506 again it
seemed like ages from the Bradley to get
from our position in central Ramadi
Malad to the curricular aid station and
I do remember when I got there the the
medic gave me a little shot of morphine
and like three minutes go by and talk
about losing your composure and I'm in
freaking pain and I I regret saying this
it was just like stupid things you say
well things are going wrong and I
grabbed him by the collar I'm like I'm a
Navy SEAL
you've got to wrap that shit up and you
know I can tell the look of sort of
frustration in his eye he comes back and
sticks me and finally like the morphine
hits and the pain subsided but what I
remember vividly is one they had very
little capability for surgery in fact no
they're all and they had a purpose in to
forty forty sixes were inbound to get us
and who shows up Dave Wommack Colonel
MacFarland I'm sorry Colonel Ron Clark
and the senior leadership from the first
of the Volvo six in fact there was
probably a hundred soldiers out there
and so they bring us out on the
stretchers we're strapped down and Dave
Wommack has some Oakleys
still midday and he puts them on me
laying on the stretcher and I flew off
with those Oakley's and if you know the
army they don't get good gear especially
in the infantry that guy just gave me is
like a high protection that it flew off
with but they saw us off and next thing
I know I end up in Allen dr. Kato mmm TQ
TQ yeah for surgery and again who's
waiting for me Rob your counterpart and
all the boys and so the you know before
they rush into surgery and put us under
Rob was there but they thought and in
retrospect you know III still struggle
with this because I was almost upset
with it at a time it was almost like
rubbing a dog's face in its own feces
for taking a crap on the carpet is they
thought we would want to see Mikey and
so they laid both of us right by Mikey
who was declared deceased by this point
it was almost like a point of shame a
point of utter shame and just kidding
good luck you know other seals and tears
I'm in tears but I just couldn't look
and I know they they had nothing but the
best intent but at the time it was just
there was a guy don't want to see us I
know what I did I know what happened so
they did that he give us about five
minutes and then rushed us into surgery
and uh you know next thing I know I wake
up in Baghdad and go through another
procedure and then prepped to get the
medevac to Germany to go through another
procedure and the great thing is you
know that others heal and I were
together the entire time they gave us
two seals to escort us and you know
Germany were there for I think three
days and just people kept this inning
and visiting and yeah at the time it's
just I didn't want to talk to anyone I
didn't want to talk to you and Seth and
that's what I talked to you for the
first time was when you got to Germany
and it's cuz I had I had my sitrep to
pass and I don't know how I'm sure
because the other seal the for sealing
on that rooftop state was Seth he Seth
was aware of what had happened but I
needed to talk to you guys to be like
hey he jumped on that thing and in the
military when somebody jumps on the
green grenade you know what that means
it is the most selfless act of valor
that there is and it needs to be
reported because usually if the medical
records check out the the due diligence
is done and it shows that it is truth it
is a medal of honor and I think that's
where I started this I tation to get to
you and then after the three days there
we just FYI the only thing you told me
which I asked you I was trying to ask
you questions about hey man or you know
okay how's the other seal that's wounded
and you just said we're like that's all
you were telling me it was about my key
it's all you were telling me morphine is
a hell of a drug no man it's because you
you wanted to make sure I knew what was
going on you wanted to make sure that
what happened you want to ensure that I
knew that you didn't care about anything
else
that you were just like he this is what
he did this is what he did I'm telling
you this is what he did I'm like I know
man I got it I'm like are you okay he's
act you like don't care this is what he
did he saved me he saved this guy he
saved all three of us up there that was
the only thing you cared about and so
then you got home and
and yeah I remembered you know people
ask me about like you know the the
funerals of my guys but I wasn't ever
there because I was you know we were
still deployed but I know that this
point you were and I know that's uh I
can't even imagine for you what that
process was like it was shame yeah the
the way Mikey passed it's one of the
most intimate ways like brothers can
pass with one another it's you know
we're out there in the conduct of a
fight a guy gets shot laying down fire
it's selfless but when somebody makes a
sacrifice but you haven't already made
that that is that is a message that hey
this is my gift to you keep my memory
alive and live well but to the guy that
is saved you all you feel is shame and I
know you you felt these same sort of
feelings is you know ultimately you're
responsible for these guys and I think
we all conducted our career with God
helped me if there isn't anything I
could have done in the planning and risk
mitigation and preparation for this
mission or during the conduct of the
mission that brings my guys home then I
am wrong and that is on me and so to
come home even though everyone was was
so welcoming and gracious and and and
caring it just you feel this this like
just blanket of shame and funny enough
when they had these buses waiting for us
at some San Diego Airport because
remembered it was it was a some private
jet that took us from Bethesda to San
Diego and so they loaded us up on the
bus and then straight to Balboa and my
ex-wife and my daughter
we're waiting there and get my daughters
to at the time but she would not come to
me they they had a little sign welcome
home daddy
and you know my ex-wife kept trying they
because I'm still on a stretcher tried
try to keep giving my daughter to me and
she just wouldn't she was cleaning onto
my aunt's would not come to me and it
was just even that like I remember that
so vividly and I think it in a subtle
way like I held that against my daughter
for a short while he's like it was just
like it was almost like a shunning like
she knew what happened she was like
shunning me I bottom-line she was scared
yeah yeah bottom line she's a
two-year-old yeah my cam needs to be in
with mom but just just being at a
funeral in everything and just looking
at all you know watching all the seals
there to you know to celebrate Mikey's
life it just it felt like that high
school on me too that's that's a selfish
feeling hey this isn't about you
whatsoever but it was just this like how
can how can how did I let that happen
and why didn't you jump like how could
you not get there in time are you slow
could you not assess what are you stupid
and I still don't have a good answer for
that you know but what really just you
know we talked about this is like
somebody needs to hold me accountable
that's why I felt like somebody needs to
hold me accountable and you know the
boys pick me up for the funeral and of
course me and the other guy pack up the
wheelchairs throw them in the back of
the suburban and when we get to the the
mass prior to the the funeral miss
Monsour is just waiting and you know I'm
ready to to own what had happened and
before you know I can't even get the
words out she wraps her horns around the
other seal and I and says I'm so happy
you're home thank you for being with my
son
and at that point you're like okay I
have no idea what to say you just
totally threw me off my game but you
should be upset you just lost your son
and you are thanking me for being with
your son and you're telling me you are
so happy that I'm home I talked about
like in felling the ultimate mind thank
him but that is just a testament of the
family that Mikey came from and for the
audience
Mikey was a Southern California kid
again pretty big kid about 6 to probably
about 2/10 dry sense of humor and was a
devout Catholic in the family still fun
I don't want you to think of this like
straight religious family daily but they
are resolute in their beliefs and
they're from Southern California and
they're the most selfless family I've
ever met when you meet them and you
spend time with them you quickly realize
where Mike he got it and he went to
every mass at Corregidor when I say Mass
it's in a bombed-out building with some
military priests and about five people
one of which is Mikey passing out
communion and he had faith and getting
to know the family was actually very
easy after that but with time as time
went on you know you begin to feel like
you're a reminder of their son and not
the best light and so I think over time
I you know I pulled away from the family
to give them their their rest because at
some point they have to put it down in
the bottom of their lives and I don't
know if that's the right call I'm Han I
still struggle with that today but I
mean I love the family even there was a
sense of guilt from my parents when they
met their parents just how good people
feel like why their son and not ours or
my parents or think don't get me wrong
they're extremely grateful but there was
a sense of guilt throughout our entire
family that we get to move on in their
family lives with this burden much like
we do for the rest of their lives
well I can tell you that when you said
it's a reminder not in a good way
I would actually dispute that with you
and I promise you that it's it's a man
they they love they love hearing from
you and talking to you and and anyone
the same the same with mark same with
Ryan same with same with all of our
friends that have fallen if you can go
go and tell a story that they haven't
heard before or to tell a story that
they've heard a hundred times before
it's it's it's worth it it's worth it at
what point did you realize that you were
gonna heal quick enough to go back in to
another platoon actually they told me to
take a take a knee and they wanted to
give me orders out of team three and to
take a easy tour and relax which is the
strangest thing I would ever think to
hear from a bunch of seals co-leaders it
was actually okay I mean you get back in
the game as quickly as possible cuz
that's what's best for you
so talked him out of the fact that
you're not sending me away from SEAL
team 3 so what do they do in response to
that they aligned me into another
platoon that is heading to pick up for
the listeners Paycom means specific men
that means we're going over the
Philippines to work with the the
Philippine SEALs and evil not be in
combat mning host nation building and
funny enough when they align the
platoons there's these little placards
with your face and in your name and in
the Master Chief's it's a big magnet a
big magnet we'll call it the Ouija board
because that's how they stack up who's
going where and so the Master Chief's
office this is a no kidding story was
open and they've got the three task
units with each of the platoons
underneath them the two platoons and all
the pictures of who's in wahpeton and
I'm in this platoon gonna pick on them
so what I do is take my magnet take some
junior officer that's an a oh I see in a
CENTCOM platoon going back to Iraq put
my picture there put his picture in the
paper
literally go up to the Pettine space and
getting well so the guy's name say hey
so-and-so you've just been a resize to
this platoon go report it and I'm not
kidding you that is how that happened
and no one ever said a thing either one
they didn't they didn't recognize that
it happened or two they're just like
okay we're not talking about at this
point and I screwed over a kid by
sending him to take off first but first
lieutenant yeah I don't feel all that
bad about it yeah so you knew how long
it take you to heal up so it was about
uh four months of debridement so you
know when I had some holes that were as
deep as half a golf ball the end if you
don't pick the scab off then it'll heal
in a concave manner so this little
doctor female doctor had to go in every
day and she would pick at this gap to
keep the wound fresh so that it yields
out called her doctor pain but did that
for about four months then I had to get
the legs working and actually start to
walk and then run but overall four
months because remember when a team
comes back from a deployment to go into
a six month individual training cycle so
guys can go to Sniper school and so I
had time to heal but there's still a lot
of shrap metal in my in my legs we form
up with the platoon I'd put on some bad
weight and then you know throughout that
entire - - your trading training cycle
in fact a guy named Eric Benson and we
both know and Derek was killed on
extortion 17 would cut into my legs the
the trap metal that was pushing towards
the skin he would remove it so I had a
little jar of shrap metal throughout
that two-year period that he would he
would take out and he loved it you love
the medicine side yeah and then you roll
back back to Iraq yeah you do you
remember it with anything in work up any
spectacular or give me that look most
people that I put through work up give
me that look suea have been working for
Jocko you know eyes were gonna be on me
naturally I put it on myself one of
those uh
self-inflicted pressures that he's gonna
accept
feck me too to perform at a higher level
given the amount of combat experience
I'd had and you had by that point
drastically changed how the West Coast
SEAL Teams to prepare for war and it was
you know it was good pressure I liked
pressure
I like when somebody holds me
accountable and you know I think echo
and I were talking about this you have a
very uncanny way of having a
conversation without saying a word sort
of you know the eyebrows come down lower
and you they just stare and what I've
said is like you would you would do that
and look at me during the Train and be
like hey here's the standard for
everyone else here's your standard get
it done good talk and so I you there
were probably runs brows harder on
myself than you were but uh I do
remember now military operations are
terrain specifically in Kentucky and
that was some of the best training we'd
gone through and again that was
drastically different than the prior
worked out and proud Ramadi and for the
guys that had not seen combat given what
happened on the next deployment that
would that absolutely prepared us for uh
for what happened yeah I mean coming
back that was so ideal for me to go back
and run training I mean if there's no
better job I could and that's you know I
was a little really lucky that I did
good relationship with the Admiral and
he said like where do you want to go and
I said I want to go run train at because
I need to get these guys ready because
when we got back Ramadi wasn't done yet
it ended up finishing up pretty quickly
thereafter but I was just thinking hey
everyone's gonna be going back and doing
the same thing for another
the average counterinsurgency last seven
years this started six months ago we got
like many years worth of fighting and
these guys need to be ready for that
specific thing that I know how to do and
so I need to go run that training and
that's what I did and I was definitely
it's funny because like when you're
talking about like but like I there was
a lot of buddy carrying going on and
when I was running training and the
reason is because I I got the debrief
you know like it's I knew it's like this
is going to be if you get in this
situation it's not it's not what you
think it is it's going to be hell
how do you prepare for it you prepare
for it you do his clothes you make this
as close to combat as you can possibly
make it
then that was my goal and it was
freaking hard training and I you know I
had so many guys come back over the
years after that when I was running
training that were like hey you know I
just got back from Afghanistan thank you
and the firefights were literally easier
than going through a block of land
warfare they would be so stoked and it
was awesome that's like the best
compliments I've ever gotten in my life
was having those guys come back and and
also I was just talking to as a matter
of fact I was talking to the guy that
told me that you were good to go
the other day and he's he's like oh we
would had so many blue on blues if we
didn't go through that workup we were so
much better
we were so prepared and they had a band
of freaking hardcore deployment to
Afghanistan and they kicked ass and he's
like yeah we were totally good to go
because that training set us up and so
that was uh that was a real honor for me
to be able to get to do that but yeah I
was a little bit I was also a little bit
still like I remember I remember and
I've talked about this before in the
podcast but like I'd be in mount like it
watching urban training going on and I'd
see like a new guy or something like
standing in the middle of street and I
would literally feel like a sickness in
my stomach like a pit like just like
when I was in Ramadi if you'd see
someone the street you'd be like dude
get off the street I would have that
feeling and so when I'd go over and talk
to him it would you generally be like
like pretty hostile like bro what the
hell are you doing you're in the middle
of street get out of here you're gonna
get freaking killed and so yeah it was
good and it was good that we put you
guys through that because you guys went
right back into the fire right back into
the fire on that next deployment and you
know leading into that the last month I
had my son who I named after Mikey so
his name is Michael Anthony Sorelli
there's Michael Anthony Mansour he knows
he's not named after me so I get to see
him born less than two weeks after that
we all end up in DC to see Mikey
posthumously recognized with the Medal
of Honor and then from Washington DC I
fly directly to to the Middle East and
then in Iraq
I mean they literally but it up when we
were deploying again and so we end up
back in a lien bar province Iraq I end
up specifically in Ramadi which is
completely different completely pacified
and part of you just can't even believe
it you just like no no it's wait just
wait it's coming they're gonna attack
and no it's not that way what at the
same time we were arriving in Iraq the
solder militia backed by Iran Iranian
special groups they're what we call the
cuts forces they're their Special Forces
had kicked off a major Spring Offensive
in the spring of 2008 and so the Army is
getting hammered inside of Sadr City
soldiers are dying and they request
sniper support from the US Special
Operations Command specifically see just
sort of AP and that siege is sort of
knowing that SEAL team 3 had run that
similar mission in support of the one
one ready combat Brigade the deployment
prior said hey can you guys run this
mission so our commander at the time and
Master Chief were faced with a decision
we had commitments and a lien bar
products he just couldn't shut down a
location and send that entire unit to
Sadr City they that wasn't gonna work
so he had to make a decision of taking
seals from all the particulars in a lien
bar and thrown them into sort of this
hodgepodge unit so you had seals from
two different SEAL Teams thrown together
and we loaded up a bunch of our geez I
think 818 all and 40 of us drove out to
the Baghdad International Airport and
set up a new unit called debt defender
detachment and Naval Special Warfare
detachment detachment Baghdad and we
named it defender Saint Michael
Archangel the defender after Mikey and
we created this badass patch that had
the Archangel on there and we all knew
in some of my keys boys that had gone
through buds were in this new unit and
good good friends of mine that weren't
in Iraq at that time they had deployed
to the Philippines and so we are located
in Baghdad but Sadr City is like an hour
and 15 minutes away from Baghdad
International Airport and so you know
they are screaming for us to get in and
again this unit has never worked
together some of them have like these
three guys came from the spittoon they
had worked together but they hadn't
worked with these guys in the SEAL Teams
and the both of conventionals and siege
of sodor first screamin for us to get in
there and so we did the best we could
rehearsals the planning we had never
operated in the area maybe some people
had but those were the very senior SEALs
and we get thrust into Sadr City
primarily around this this route called
route gold and they were trying to at
that point the strategy was to cordon
off or enclose Sadr City with these
large T barriers so that we can control
the entry points into the city and hence
cut off supplies or enemy troops coming
into the city and ultimately this
strategy worked but the first night in
all 40 of us go in and again remember we
had this like young Intel officer who
had just come from first time in Iraq
had come from Ali and bar where you're
dealing with now the remnants of a Sunni
enemy and we're now operating in Shia
territory against Shia enemy completely
two different styles of fighting two
different purposes one will get their
jihad on to the point where they die
others are not necessarily gonna give
them a life so they're gonna fight and
then pull back and then fight another
day
and he didn't understand really the
difference and so the Intel wasn't
exactly in lining again we hadn't been
in the area we go in the first night and
all hell breaks loose Chris Kyle's with
us
he's our lead sniper we're trying to get
into a position and I mean we had EF
peas detonated on our Patrol for the
listeners an EFP is an explosive forming
project
again if you remember these were
iranian-made
and what it is is a concave plate of
copper with a lot of explosives behind
it when you detonate it it turns it into
a molten projectile molten because
bullet yes and this thing could cut
through Bradley and RG and Abrams tank
come right through like a hot knife
through out the butter these things were
nasty and they were killing troops we
had that detonated on us and then they
owned the rooftops and they had what we
were trying to do to them and so we are
just like fish in a fishbowl and they
are shooting chris took one round in the
helmet announced off and you know Seth
had now taken your position as the and
it really is the band got back together
to ask you to bruiser
and so Seth is back with the Stryker
company that inserting us doing his job
at deconfliction making sure we had the
support we needed and shortly after we
called for hot extract I mean guys were
getting low on ammo the enemy's
manoeuvring RPGs pecan on the roof tops
down into us how we do not lose a guy I
will never know and what I like to say
is that Marc Ryan and Mikey were looking
after us hey you got this one we're
gonna give this one to you it reset but
we called Seth in and know behold I do
remember this about Seth is as the
strikers come in strikers are it's like
an armored version of a Humvee with
wheels that can carry more troops than
Humvee larger and they have some pretty
good armament weapon systems and the
ramp lowers and Seth runs off and starts
firing into dunnock and of course it's a
stylish sight let's go get all the
strikers and the guys start loading up
and the strikers are and getting after
it to the point where they went
Winchester getting us out of there and
one of this striker operators says hey
give me your gun I hand him my
sr-25 and he just starts going at it my
enemy
last Maggie reloads and he's just
getting after it well today what
humbling experience put us back into the
same position like a new guy in Ramadi
okay hey we've got some great experience
we got a reset and we we said hey give
us like 36 hours we need you to some
serious planning we need to do some
serious we're Herschel's we did that and
then we inserted shortly after that but
you know the funny thing is the only
time I got really felt vulnerable and I
remember I called my brother before we
inserted the next time they said hey I
don't think things are gonna work out
here but my kids know hello hey and make
sure you know my daughter grows up to be
a personal character and make sure my
grand mind my son grows up to be a man
and me and my brother don't talk all
that much but for me to make that call
was probably a bad choice and for him to
hear that probably put a lot more
concern on his plate but we inserted and
we got into position and the guy started
to knock it out of the park and then
mission after mission they just kept
eliminating combatants sig axe started
to dive
we had one 72-hour operation where the
guys eliminated 50 fighters and within
three weeks I think I want to limit it
and I don't want to hyperbole here or
plus-up numbers I think was like 125 to
150 within three weeks the guys
eliminated and sig axe went to almost
zero and then there was not much to do
for the rest of the plan well holdy gang
with significant activities that's enemy
attacks basically but what's also
interesting is that at the tail end of
that the sheiks inside Sadr said he came
out and said hey look we're good like
we're here to make friends now what
we're done with this and what was really
awesome was it Sadr City had been a
complete nightmare for five straight
years I mean solder city was completely
uncontrollable and then in a six week
period - give or take that that those
operations took place it was like done
it was like they the the sheiks came out
and said yup we'll keep this under
control we want to make peace and and
that's what happened that was that was a
that was unbelievable
set of circumstances do you know the one
thing in that deployment or never in in
you know it should I'd earn cess trust
because of the distance between the
Baghdad International Airport in Sadr
City the conventional unit that was
supporting us when we go into Sadr was
in outside of Sadr City soon as I came
like and I think I think I spent all
three weeks there he's like hey stay
there plan the missions if you need to
do a recce of the site go out with the
conventionals and so for three weeks
like I wasn't with the boys it would
move to me and then we would execute the
mission but you know learning what we
had about you leave effort and putting
your ego aside in building personal
capital through relationships we built a
great relationship with the the 10th
mountain and they gave us anything we
needed and there's a lot of lessons
learned from Ramadi that were you know
we took in that we actually stepped up
in terms of the mission planning of
preparation with some of the assets that
the 10th Mountain had but I was going
out with the confessionals by myself
if I needed to get to another out
station or a cop they would have a
convoy of Bradley's waiting for me just
from me and I loved it but Seth realized
I was probably getting a little off the
reservation at one point we conducted a
mission we got back to that that larger
base and he said hey go get your stuff
and coming back and I'm like I actually
think I barked a little of them he's
like go get yourself another bag that
was pissed because I was loving I was
Colonel Kurtz innocence loving it yeah
he you know he made the right call sir
yeah I know you guys didn't outstanding
job there and again it wasn't obviously
it wasn't just you guys the 10th
Mountain did freaking unbelievable job
the some of the images that were coming
back at that time of those guys putting
that T barrier up right in the middle or
right at the what side of Sadr City was
at the eastern side of Sadr City
then you could see those guys out there
putting that barrier putting those
barriers up the conventional army guys
it was freakin awesome man
what what what all those awesome guys
then you come back from that deployment
you think you maybe you had enough yet
not really you know on that in that vein
i sat down with that commanding officer
of Team 3 at the time
and you know I've gotten orders to an
East Coast team and you know he was do
my final fit rent and send me off really
pretty pretty good relationship and he's
eight him Mike the last thing I want to
leave you with is at some point it
becomes about family and I'm looking at
them and I pause for about ten seconds I
said Roger that sir but within the
hamster wheel turning in my head it was
are you freaking kidding me I'm gonna
deploy as much and as often as I can
because this thing is not gonna last
forever and I'm going to another command
with a bunch of warriors and I want to
get right and stride and deploy as much
as possible but in retrospect towards
the end I realized what he was trying to
tell me at some point you gotta pull
back yeah so it only took you another
what seven eight years to figure that
out so you get out to the East Coast and
now you're doing just more deployments
yeah first one was to Afghanistan with a
great group of guys man you know I loved
loved these guys different feel to him
but my first mission out was probably
one of the toughest missions I've ever
been on in terms of just like terrain
because wherever echoing our problems
now and then how I would describe cone
our province is man town take you know
some of the worst areas of the Colorado
Rockies and then maybe multiply it by
two and the enemy I mean they were this
was their territory they had prepared
positions it was a dangerous area to put
it into perspective a little more for
for the listeners you know of all the
medals of honor within Afghanistan I
think the majority all of them were in
that tone are nursed an area to to glued
Dakota miners and on the first mission
the IHS was like an eight-hour suck fest
and I
actually so Adam Braun was was killed on
that operation and that was my sort of
baptism to fire to that new unit and I
remember I looked at a good friend Jonas
was killing destruction 17 I said hey
bro are both missions like that okay I
just want to make sure I need to get my
head right but um it was good to work
with that team and get that experience
and then I got a lot of time with the
maritime side as well the boats but did
in all with them what was that
seven more deployments with great guys
and you know lost some more brothers
namely extortion 17 which was the
largest loss of life in Afghanistan just
you know it it's a travesty when we lose
one soldier marine sailor and airmen but
when you lose 31 that is just you know
that hits the military to the listeners
they may say well 31 yeah
soldiers you guys can easily recover
from them you can't all the the
man-hours that go into training those
guys the level of proficiency they had
crewed over years like that is like that
is a catastrophic failure or uh you know
detriment to the military that is a loss
of a lot of capability I yet alone the
pain for those 31 families the children
the or not the orphans but the kids ever
left behind the Y's that are left behind
and that will never have any solace
other than that their loved ones were
for doing what they believed in for them
defending them
but overall I mean grade 7 years in just
nothing but lessons learned and
leadership lessons in terms of being a
troop commander in quite frankly you
know my last experience I
learned a lot which was not my best
leadership experience you know you look
at extreme ownership and there's ways I
could have handled certain situations
better and I think I reflect on my
entire military career just on man I
could have done that better that's what
we all do that back and think man we
could have done that better it goes back
to what I was saying earlier about like
if you know the way then the way appears
everywhere but when you don't know it
you're seeing like little like even I
remember when I was young man young and
I do something that was like partially
right but then I do something that
wasn't and I think of myself if I would
have known if I would have gotten some
reinforcements if I would have figured
it out better you know like figured it
out better and you just don't and that's
one of the hardest things about a lot
hardest things about it's not just the
SEAL Teams it's the military when you
complete a job you don't get to do it
anymore
you you you get done with your assistant
platoon commander and you're like okay I
got this figured out I'm ready to do it
again they're like no now you're gonna
be a platoon commander and then you get
done with your platoon commander you
okay I got this figured out
I'm ready to do em they gonna know
you're gonna be attached to the
commander then you as soon as you get
you figure something out you're done
with that job and you can't go back and
you very seldom do you get to go back
and you yes so we all sit around and
look back and and and there's another
weird thing about this whole deal this
whole deal is that it's so hard to if
someone's gotta have a real open mind to
be able to teach it to people you know
someone's got to be when if someone's
gonna have an open mind like I would say
when I was running trade at I would say
like thirty or forty percent of the
people would be like listening and
absorbing and at which is it which is
pretty good it's actually pretty good
but there was like thirty percent of the
people that you know I would try and
explain something to him and it just
wouldn't they just wouldn't like you're
putting the way in front of them but
what they don't recognize it they can't
they can't see it and so it's easy now
that you know the way when you look back
at your own experience as you go the way
appears everywhere but you didn't see it
I didn't see it back then I'm just
looking at it going burn why didn't I
one that figure that out it's one of
those things and I think that's one of
the things that that makes what I'm
doing now what you're doing what we're
doing now as a team is to be able to try
and pass these lessons on to leaders
everywhere and you know leaders in the
military leaders and police leaders and
fire leader and business AG everyone to
be able to say look hey this is it over
here I know this is hard to see but look
at this and and it's awesome to be doing
what we're doing now and say oh and have
people again of a certain percentage of
people that go I got it I got it I can
take that and what's interesting about
our business now is when people are
raising their hand and they're asking
for it that means their mind is open to
they're open to it they want it whereas
with and this does happen occasionally
when we work with companies that we're
getting imposed on you know like the
Board of Directors and hey go fix this
company this company screwed up you
gotta go fix them those people don't
have open months so they're they're
looking when you're talking to them
they're looking for reasons that what
you're saying is wrong that's their goal
is to say no that doesn't apply to me it
doesn't apply to this market doesn't it
snow we actually work with eight
companies in your exact industry your
competitors and they have the same
problem this is how they fix it but no
it's different for us okay it's
different for you it's different for you
leadership is different and your
specific company leadership is different
than it is everywhere else no that's
actually not true not true at all so
it's an unfortunate you know it's I've
been thinking about this too cuz you
know I got I got a I got a son you know
I got three daughters in a son and and
and the fact of the matter is you don't
see yourself as much in your daughters
as you do and your son right your son is
a he's a he's a a boy a small man and
man what I wouldn't give to be able to
just like put the knowledge in there you
know cuz you see him doing stuff and you
go and you could you know this is my own
flesh and blood by the way that I say
hey that's not a good way to handle that
here's a good way to handle it and he
looks at me like I'm an idiot right like
how would you ever know what it's like
deal with a schoolteacher you know want
to deal with a coach how would you know
what that's like to deal with another
person you know what you're right I'm
sure you have this you're 15 now I'm
sure you got it all figured out this is
the one thing I leave kids with and I
gotta tell you you might my old man was
probably right 95 percent of the time
but did I listen
no no no door is your father's come up
to me and be like hey can you talk to my
son he loves you wants to be a seal I
what can you leave him with listen to
your old man he may not know what the
right decision is or right path is on
certain things but he will tell you what
the wrong path is sometimes knowing what
not to do is as valuable as knowing what
to do you know what else I tell when
when fathers asked me to talk to their
sons
I tell the sons I say listen your dad
actually cares about you more than you
do he wants an outcome for you a good
outcome for you more than you do I know
that doesn't seem possible but for him
to come and ask me to like talk to you
means that what he wants more than
anything in the world is for you to be
in a good place in the future that's
what he wants he doesn't want to screw
you over this isn't a plot to get you to
fail in life he actually wants you to
win more than anything so you may want
to listen to him check so it's at this
point you do you do so what do you have
you did nine deployments overseas total
ten nine ten ten deployments overseas
and and finally the little voice in your
head says you know what I need to look
at something else
probably probably the toughest decision
I had to make I mean a lot of guys like
a lot of guys thought you were a 30-year
vet easy he's gonna do 30 probably more
and they usually said the same about me
in that Ken and I were talking about
this it just came over me like a like a
wave just crushed me was just like yep
it's it it's like I'm I'm I'm tapping
out innocence at the end of the day you
always ring the bell yeah
through the community they're like are
you quitting quitter and you know I had
one last get deployment with a different
group and it was awesome to work with
these guys and you know there was a lot
of things going on one I finally felt
the the fatigue and the hardest thing to
do for any SEALs to tap out
but it's because you know that you're no
longer like the best guy to push that
unit forward and I also was going
through a divorce at the time and things
were just you know things were out of
balance and even though I wanted to take
the XO of a squadron I knew I was not
the best option for the guys and even
though I could probably maintain the job
that's not the right answer if I could
not keep them uncomfortable moving
forward then then that wasn't the right
guy and so you know we talked about
brutal self-assessments that was the
most brutal self-assessment because he I
had admit that all you know however good
I thought I was and what we did what we
did it just I'd come to a point where
things were too grating and so uh you
know overseas I actually called back to
you know mom I see how at the time I
said I'm done I'm done
and they said okay we understand that
that's a mature decision you he wanted
me to stay he's like I want you to be my
XO man he actually referred the captain
from the raid in the Philippines the
Ranger the one that did all the planning
I'm forgetting the name now but yeah he
used to call me that and I said I
understand what he want to do it's like
you want to go to Memphis in like
working the detail shop I said no hey
get me orders to to Texas my ex is
probably moving back to Texas that's
where she's from and I want to be close
to my kids I need to repair that
relationship yeah
you've talked about it you know families
come second bottom line when you're at
war you have so many responsibilities on
you one bring your guys home that the
families come second and so that was my
new priority and so
you know testament to the Selah
community they made things happen they
realign things and they got me a billet
at the University of Texas naval ROTC
we're one Admiral William McRaven was
sitting as the the UT Chancellor boom
and then so did you go to school so you
got down there and wasn't to get your
degree it no it was to be an ROTC
instructor oak and they'd also prepped
the battlefield say hey the guy wants to
get a masters degree one get four so
that was the collateral yeah just to get
your degree and so I literally had one
late week to apply for the the full-time
MBA program UT took the instead of the
GMAT I took the AC no I'm trying to
think a CT and or GRE the GRE thank you
and the scores were we're not so hot
I've had some phone calls and I got in
and you know that was a humbling
experience as well to start you know we
in a sense I don't say master Bowie
becomes very good I become being seals
at the art of war which takes years in
years to hone and even then you're never
as good as you think you are but you put
it put time in you built some level
mastery and then to step into accounting
and finance with a bunch of 27 year olds
and you're the 39 year old in the course
and you have this puzzled look on your
face because one you've been blowing up
a couple times actually I went to some
training really like yeah you've
suffered cognitive degradation to the
amount of 50 percent what make that
Excel spread slowly so I was grabbing
these younger kids like a guys were
talking about okay and they all loved me
they knew there was something different
about me and I remember it came time for
the first test and one of the younger
kids he was actually one of the owners
in the class was 26 he's like sir when's
the last time you took a test I'm like
14 years ago so shut up
but it was say it was hard stepping back
and do an academic environment people
are like well did you be in the combat
this is gonna be easy for you
hey it's like a different type of stress
brother and like you know one we we all
drive ourselves to do well and the first
few tests did not come back favorable
Mike's real easy Colin and so I buckled
down and done actually did quite well
but after the first semester the the
basics of business it gave me a good
grounding I'm like hey I think I can do
something I actually think I can do
something good pay back to the community
they hooked me up to be here where
there's no military base I'm supposed to
go back to the community and I know
there's there's a problem with that's
getting out especially SEALs they're not
getting jobs commensurate with their
abilities and company should be
swallowing these guys up leaders I mean
the one thing you can't deny is the
military is the preeminent leadership
training platform in the nation no
debating it I'm not slightly the world
if I'd be the world I'm not saying
there's not great leaders out there that
have not been in the military actually
they're there they're more than that
people would like to think there's a lot
of great leaders and never had military
training but as a whole and as you've
said about the Marine Corps they tend to
turn out this this this standard product
which is a kind of buff and the same
thing with the military in general and
so you know talking Admiral McRaven and
a great guy named who was his vice
chancellor Major General Tony cool oh
yeah this guy's become a real big better
than he loved them we talked about this
and business walked myself into a
project which we got approved by the
McCombs business school 20 vets we did a
analysis into the systemic challenges
facing veterans when they get out in
terms of employment and it was a 60 page
paper which was met with quite a better
reception and then again walking myself
into more work everyone's like hey dude
we think you guys have a business
concept of this around this paper you
need to take it one step further won't
war prove another project the next
semester and heads
something called vetted was formed and
to give a quick brief on vetted so
vetted having done all the gap analysis
of current programs out there and all
the research we did we feel we found a
solution and actually Huffington Post
held vetted as revolutionising the way
that veterans exit the military so it is
bar none the most comprehensive program
out there and it's still building itself
up so a partnership between the Wharton
University of Texas McCombs MBA program
and the Texas A&M maze business program
an MBA program we developed something
called the veteran accelerated
management program it's optional five
months of online education through the
Wharton Business foundations course as a
preparatory to a two-month in-house
residence program that basically gives
them a very strong business acumen over
the within that two months over the
course of their seven months they've
received more career development which
is almost as important as acquiring the
business skills then an MBA student gets
in two years and that's how do you
review how you refine your resume
optimize your resume LinkedIn mock
interviews but they hit all the basic
verticals in business even entrepreneurs
if they have a business idea they come
in they have a executable business plan
on the back end and for those I want to
go into industry actually every Thursday
Friday they're working on a yeah
industry capstone embedded in the
company so during that eight week 70
Thursday Friday working the project
inside a company which means industry
experience that can go in their resume
and then two organizations offered their
placement services free of charge at the
end national on front overwatch and rabi
Morris Inc which the to happen to be
strategic partners which I'm sure we'll
get into but of the first pilot program
at the University of Texas McCombs of
the 25 veterans all are placed except
for one yeah so that so you just kind of
start talking about the next thing
obviously we need to talk about is
you know at some point while you were
doing this and your life and I were with
national on front and we work with
companies all the time and every company
we work with guess what they need they
need people they need good people any
they need leaders that's what they need
and you know as you and I discussed this
and talked about it and I don't know if
I don't know who made the connection
mentally I think it was you who made the
connection mentally you're like oh wait
you you need people and we're making
people let's figure that out and that's
sort of where we got into this idea of
national on front overwatch we did it
was it was just combining chocolate
peanut butter Reese's Pieces it was
magical sorry with so you know there was
a lot of lessons learned from teddy and
you know when I started that there was a
lot of business manners of mine very
successful business matters that are
like dude you need to capitalize this
thing and at the time I couldn't see it
like my alter altruism sort of drove
like no it needs to be nonprofit we're
gonna charge people for this now I
recognize that in a capitalistic market
you can do more good on the for-profit
side than you can the nonprofit side we
live in a free society free enterprise
and I remember sitting down in Austin
with you guys I'm like hey I remember
you telling me that every company you
talk to is like we're gonna get like
five of you and that just wasn't your
game at the time yeah but at the end of
the day you know talent is all about
leadership becoming a talent magnet or
having a talent mindset within your
organization is about leadership and so
you know knowing our communities the
Special Operations community in combat
aviators Dave Burke your resident
fighter pilot the badass good deal death
we knew we could start something and so
we created special on front overwatch
what we call EF overwatch overwatch
being the term that the mission we ran
it in Ramadi and I think like it has a
little appeal in the sense that now
we're over watching our brothers Green
Berets Navy SEALs Air Force PJ's CC tees
barsaat guys getting out and the direct
support come personnel
we're over watching them and help them
with their transition we're over watch
the companies that are in a war for
talent that's the thing that people
don't understand even the seals are
always hunting for the best talent
somebody asked me you know funny enough
with the with the most important job and
the SEAL Teams is and they they thought
it was gonna say a true commander on the
frontlines and that that is important at
the end of the day that's what we do I
said no it's actually but being above
budget trucker that is like being a
hiring manager you are the filter of the
talent coming through which ultimately
will end up in that troop commander and
that that troop Chiefs hands and there
has to be a standard and we need to put
some of our best guys at Budds to make
sure that only the best are passing
through well the same thing applies to
business you are constantly in this war
for talent and we couldn't think of a
better talent pool than combat aviators
Cobra pilots fighter pilots again all
the Special Operations guys and the
direct support personnel that come out
of SOCOM that have the soft skills the
leadership skills that you want they may
lack the hard skills you look at their
resume and it may not scream right fit
yeah
but once you get these guys in an
interview and you see that one day
they're leaders that they're humble but
they're willing to roll their sleeves up
and get after it and actually listen and
learn that is the perfect employee if
you can get more of these guys into your
business I guarantee you you will create
your own army that will dominate your
battlefield in whatever industry that
you're in it's it's it's awesome because
people every every single time I go to a
company they'll they'll say man it seems
like you just it seems like you know did
you do a bunch of research to figure out
did you have you been working with us
and we didn't know about it and I'd be
like no well how do you know what
problems we have it's like oh cuz you're
a company because you're a group of
individual happen and guess what there's
dynamics there that happen with all
different organizations that two get
together and guess what if you take
these leaders because they're amazed
that I can understand their business
it's like no I don't understand your
business I understand leadership that's
what that's what Ashkelon front we
understand leadership so we can go in
and and look at what's going on and say
oh you've got a leadership problem here
and here's how we fix it and so to take
that and say you know what we can
actually give you people that understand
leadership and make an
help you solve these problems that is
like you said Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
peanut butter and chocolate that's what
it is
so it's been on speaking of bringing on
talent like when this whole thing was
going down a psycho but we get a little
Mike's irelia that's the long front
because guess what that's what we did
yeah bring bring the band back together
and you know that's why that's just been
it's been awesome if anyone that's come
to the monster you know Mike's Mike's
putting putting on a great talk about
leadership inside the monster forget
everyone loved it I myself included and
yeah going out working with companies
again now we just have someone else on
the team that can get out there that
understands leadership that sees
solutions we're bring it we've been
bringing you out on a bunch of stuff now
so you see other companies and you see
you're starting to take even what you
learned in school put that on top of the
practical applications that we see now
you know the way so you see it
everywhere you look so that's that's
that's another benefit so that's where
you're at now talk about getting out I
mean you talk about what get you out of
the bed in the morning in every company
is like do you love what you do I'm like
the fact that Jocko way for myself JP
Dave Flynn are on a phone call talking
about leadership I'm like there's
nothing against us having that more than
that like we actually like we love to
solve these problems because we've seen
them before yeah and you know people
people often say like well how are you
how this feels like synonymous with
business I'm like you just said it
you're a unit you're a company you're
dealing with people deal with the same
issues and it has been great I mean how
long have I been on now three months
yeah and I just love it and you know
what my fiancee sees a different person
cuz uh
frou-frou the listeners I took a you a
high-level job in higher education the
executive director of veteran services
for the Texas A&M System and it just you
know even though the work was rewarding
it just wasn't the same as being part of
national on front and like Jordan has
seen she's like you're actually how did
he get out of bed mid morning now yeah
I'm with the boys yeah
that makes a big difference and like you
said you can't even shut us up like we
will have a like we got this thing
called the tank where we'll get together
and talk about like a leader like for
working with three companies and
there'll be leadership issues at each
one of the companies and so we'll talk
about the leadership issue and then how
that problem should be approached and
these calls that are scheduled for an
hour will end up on the phone 302 and a
half hours or will end up in the in the
tank for three hours sitting there going
by and because we're learning from it
we're also learning how we can apply
what we're talking about it's just it's
just it's just an awesome it's awesome
to be part of the organization and and
like you said to be with people that are
just into it into it it mean of the
funny thing is having gotten my MBA the
one thing that is not addressed in any
MBA program is leadership yeah and they
know it and right now you're seeing a
lot of MBA programs set up or stand up
centers of leadership within their their
MBA program so they're and you know I've
had some great discussions I mean great
professors there and some really strong
leaders because they they were private
sector leaders before they came back and
spoke but I mean you can and they turn
out highly successful business
practitioners but at the end the day
like it's not a recipe for for
leadership training whatsoever yeah no
let's it's it's been awesome that's
that's why the business has gone so
great because there's no one that's
often what we're doing there's there's
there's people say well who's your
competition I'm like we don't we don't I
don't mean this in a negative way but
because I'm sure there's companies out
there that are trying to do something
but there's no one that's saying hey
this is this is what you do this is how
you lead this this is the way this will
apply to your business these are the
principles that you can use and you can
make happen so yeah that's been we've
been pretty lucky in the fact that we
saw the correlations between these two
things and so I'm pretty clearly so it's
been good and I gotta say so the muster
in DC 0:05 was my first muster and
naturally these guys know me I'm filled
with hate it's just sort of what drives
me one of my nicknames is grumpy but you
know I was definitely on board because
it's you guys you guys my brothers I'm
like yeah dude I want in
of discussing leadership but naturally
you know I always have a you hold back a
little I'm like okay let me see what
this master is about and the fact that
you guys are changing lives and people
are coming up to me off of one speech
I'm just like dude what is going on like
I gave one speech and like people are
like did you that actually your
perspective has already changed my life
I'm like well I'm glad to hear that I
didn't realize the the impact yeah
no it's it's it's it's awesome thing to
be a part of and when I say a thing to
be a part of it's awesome to be at the
muster with the people that are at the
muster not just like oh we're a part of
it and you're not no it's like everyone
that's there is a part of it and
everyone that there is there is
contributing to the knowledge that
that's being distributed and increased
so yeah it's uh it's awesome yes it's a
good time and that's where you're at now
it's probably a pretty good place to ya
probably we're touching three hours on
most right now or get two and a half or
something like that probably a good
place to call it and I'm sure we'll do
this multiple times again in the future
it of course obviously thanks for coming
on thanks for your service in the Marine
Corps in the team's and now adlai
national on front at Ashland front
overwatch clearly Mike is out here doing
his job he's done his job and now maybe
we could get EKKO to do his job and talk
about how we can all do our job better
in some way mm-hmm somehow sure could
you help us with that one
yeah sure be happy to cool we're on the
path right yeah I'm on the path you're
on the path all right chuckle chuckle
ease the path at the very least you're
all up on the path you know trying to be
on the path where I'm at good need to
get crazy alright so that being said
we're all trying to stay on the path the
best we can
so here here are the ways to do this
some ways some ways yeah yeah just some
suggestion you're like you're the
authority like this is the way the ideas
good ideas yeah proven proven most of
these are all proven yeah provided
through experience true you know etc you
know affirmative origin origin main coms
called origin our company orange
american-made stuff geez mmm rash guard
jujitsu mmm-hmm other stuff as well
apparel why does apparel get like a like
a tone you know because you know feral
have you know how you get you know the
whole like apparel like you're not a
fashion person well then again a
parallel fashion is different okay girls
what you wear as a human yeah yeah and
fashion is something else yeah that
you're trying to look a certain way
yeah or give a certain flavor to your
vibe yes I'm not a fan of you're not a
fan of flavor to your knife you just
your goal I went to when I went to
college there was this woman who was a
Buddhist monk and as I was learning
about Buddhists sure they one of the
things that they said was like you're
not supposed to stand out like just just
don't stand out yeah just just fit it
right that's part of the program yeah
technically it's not fit in its just
don't stand out okay like maybe one of
us do and if you're a practicing
Buddhist you can come on and brief me on
this I'm sure I need help
this is how I read it don't you know
just don't stand out you're just trying
to be it's it's like an ego thing right
it's like don't look at me don't look at
me because I'm just I just wear a black
t-shirt and a pair of jeans don't look
at me I'm just a normal dude over here
yeah nothing special I'm not wearing the
ling as they call it sir no so but there
was a there was a person there that was
a Buddhist monk and the Buddhist monk
wore all the Buddhist garb hmm like the
robe and the stuff which I don't care
hey I was when I was in Thailand it's
awesome it's actually awesome seeing the
Buddhist monks walk around and they
and gather rice from in the morning and
it's it's it's like awesome it seems to
be the most really chill and religion
out there right and so I'm down with the
Buddhists mm-hmm but if you're not in
Thailand with bhoot other Buddhist monks
where it's normal
yeah well then you what guess what
happens when you put on the robe you
stand stand out and you're saying look
at me and that's what I gathered from
and I was like hey don't look at me
in fact my goal is like don't look at me
that's the goal that's the goal look at
me yeah oh so okay so I think and not to
go too far deep into this so it's less
about good because when the Buddhist
puts on this garb regardless of where he
or she is when they put on the guard
that's just how that's just the garb
kind of thing here does not regardless
of where we're here where he or she is
because check it out if you're in
Thailand and you put on the normal monk
outfit sure you look normal if if you're
in a university where everyone's dressed
in western clothing shorts t-shirts and
you put on the garb then guess what
you're don't look normal right you stand
out yeah and it almost says look at me
yeah because the true in my opinion like
a like if you really wanted to to attain
that level of ego less enlightenment
enlightenment then you just be dressing
like the normal people dressed nothing
more nothing less just right down the
middle
right but don't look at me right I'm
just over here doing what I'm doing but
I think and I don't know but I think
it's possible that it's less about the
result of them standing out and more
about the effort or lack of effort or no
effort made to stand out because that's
what it is Buddhist is like you can't be
attached to like your personal it's like
you know I am same way so if you if
you're used to putting on this the garb
every day that's just how oh I'm like I
put this on
you guys I can stand out or not stand
out I'm focused I'm just not yet okay
okay well that's cool I'll change my
attitude towards the monk that I went to
college with that's what that's why he's
the the would he call it the leader cuz
he just opened you know anyway how can
origin Maine help us stay on the man
that's why if you order something from
origin Maine you could order something
that is neon green that Pete Roberts
designs yeah those fats are or have neon
or you could order something that's just
black or black and gray which is very
low pro low profile profile the joggers
and low profile looking as far as the
colors and whatnot but they're joggers
it's it's kind of hip that's the thing
right now joggers I've got a few of them
most comfortable jugglers in the world
by the way proven proven by experts
expert anyway how can I keep this on the
path okay you do Jiu Jitsu you'll stick
with you just think I need a new key
boom best key made in America by the way
see same thing this is another question
comes up all the time is should I wear
the white key the black key or the blue
key in my Buddhist mind it was always
look the white key is just the plain key
that's it
you just wear the plain white key that's
the way it is I always only wore the
white key guess what I got now lucky
guess what it doesn't matter anymore
because everybody wears all kinds of
different colored keys well they wear
white blue or black right
there's no it no longer is a thing to
wear it used to be like if you wore a
black key you're like hey look everyone
look at me right now don't give it cares
what color because there's a lot of
those different colors in circulation so
whereas a year ago I'm saying only a
year ago I would have been a like hey
listen you need to just stick with the
white key that's just how right now the
mind has been opened if you want to get
a black key if that's the one that yeah
is is you know what's your in to get a
black one yeah or the blue one or the
blue one with a green or the bright
green neon green neon green just for
clarification purposes neon green was
one of the colors that are in the spats
which are compression pants yeah anyway
see in the path
get a new key continue or start
jiu-jitsu
boom path that's right on the path right
in the middle of the path too by the way
it's not you know very nothing
Judy as part of the path also John when
I say joggers sure yes they're
comfortable I get it
comfort there's no growth in the comfort
zone mmm whatever but you're pulling
you're jogging getting accurate running
doing these things you wanna put on
sweatpants right so to speak and you put
on some comfortable made in America
origin joggers right you're still on the
path big time okay huge time actually
fair enough
there you go there you go boom so there
is growth in the comfort zone in a
certain small exceptional can you talk
any more about clothing I will be like
comfort yeah I'll be entering the
fashion area have to be like okay wait
if we talk about clothing
see even by me saying like wear this and
don't wear that that's getting in the
zone and I shouldn't be in which is
these I'm not gonna go there I'm done I
talk about supplements agree cool
supplements okay so Mike remember
supplements great when you're young take
them all yeah
what's the more what Mommy the what the
protein faster stronger and every single
way lift more ways to be more big bigger
supplements and one less working out and
then smaller t-shirts and we never
thought about hey what about joint
supplements you know like you know when
you're young you're like yeah how cool
maybe for like older folks or something
like this and I get it but nah man give
me the protein powder
give me the BCAAs right mmm so current
you know things always evolving new
information better information accurate
information joint supplements are more
important than protein powder
supplements I would agree sound agree
because look if your joints aren't
working well in lifting heavy
you don't need protein supplements
because you can't lift the weights to
get to need the recovery for the protein
and for growth and gains assume saying
that is a valid point
yeah no it you end up you're 40 and you
can barely get
your car after driving for one hour yeah
and here's the thing that that is funny
but it's not funny bro no it's not it's
real and which brings me to my other my
other point which actually all joking
aside is a big deal this is the biggest
deal that I've actually found when you
when you get more healthy joints your
everyday activity is like way different
almost still the point where you didn't
realize that you had jammed up joints
seemed saying you're like dang all this
freedom was waiting for me on the other
side of healthy joints decision making
anyway point is chocolate some
supplements those joints well Mike's
here yeah what yeah and get educated as
well anyway joint warfare krill or a
super krill oil these are things that go
directly to joints other benefits by the
way I mean talk about if you somebody
last Witter I have my knees hurt how
does joint warfare know which need to go
to you know yeah here's how that knows
the answer to that joint joint warfare
knows that it goes to both knees okay
so it's like hey hover move yeah it's
like hey we got a bunch of guys right we
got a bunch of guys they're all like
they've been working out I'm gonna say I
was gonna say like know it knows yeah
you just tell it before you eat it
before you take it more first say he
left me yeah he uh well you think it
feels like that but this is what it
really is the joint warfare doesn't know
the knees know so it's like hey look
we're all working out we're all doing
you know various we're moving we're
cleaning the guys that's what we're
doing removing the line moving our
bodies through spores anyway we're doing
the yard work alright me Mike Jocko some
other folks that we know right after all
it's hot outside yeah and then boom one
of our my wife comes outside with a big
bucket of ice with waters in it right
Jacques a little bit bigger he may have
worked a little bit harder than us he
might he might need some more water
Mike worked a little bit he might need a
certain amount of water but we all need
varying amounts of water some of the
least
what it is let's say I've been in the
shade maybe not working that much I may
be a half bottle water yeah you're
assessing yeah so my wife is the joint
warfare with all the Omega threes and
all that all the stuff the nutrients you
guys are the neat chuckles the bad knee
obviously I'm the good me I need less of
that stuff so we are the knees choose
how much water we need and this is the
what's cool about this is this is also
this is all scientific lis proving a
hundred percent that me will draw in the
journey you know the joint where fur
doesn't know the ninos check doctor echo
that's literally how it works yeah
also but yeah very important supplement
you'll know just take it you'll know and
yeah discipline you can take that you
might have seen the video that echo
Charles made about discipline that I
thought I was taking three scoops of
discipline in that it put me into let's
just call it the zone his own do just
legit the zona jiu-jitsu excellence yeah
and you spliced up that video you splice
it up I got a say thank you you splice
enough to make me look pretty good I was
all grinding on Dean that's all had
Andy's arm and I was like yeah I think
just so everyone knows yeah the rules
don't always look like that yeah well
some good little clips you only hear
something actually really funny about
that funny you bring that up okay so all
that foot remember wanna keep filmed or
whatever right and you're rolling with
Dean for a lot of that time and you know
when you roll with Dean a son you're not
just dominated Dean is good so he was
kind of getting you for a little bit
so Dean Aaron like literally that night
he's texting hey send me that footage
hey send me that foot I want to see the
footage I don't see the footage I was
you know this and that and I was like ah
you know I don't know you know I'm kind
of and he said hey I won't put something
in there just send me the footage and I
was like okay didn't send it to him I
forgot I wanted to but then I was like
shoot shit I sent him this footage you
know what like what if peoples on the
internet or whatever man that's what I'm
thinking but I'm like okay the thing as
Andy said something like that like you
were filming and Andy saw oh hey do you
want to roll even though he's here film
I was like dude I don't get her yeah
okay because shoot oh oh Jiu Jitsu
doesn't work on Jon he's not gonna tap
out no no actually just it works on
Jocko and chuckle tap it with your
freaking job and gets caught in the damn
arm
yeah yeah so so Dean wants this this
footage so I could kind of look through
the footage and there's one of him he
takes you down while he's sitting down
by the way and then he like mounts you
and he's like grinding his elbows like
let me not put that part in it yeah yeah
so I made you look good and what's sucks
is like I was doing good because I was
kind of getting after it but in yeah he
exactly made me look good so everyone me
I Thank You Dean Lister does not think a
also you know you talked about protein
not being important and I actually think
you're wrong well tank you need protein
and you might as well get your protein
from the what's commonly known as the
only real source of protein that's good
which is mulk bulk is more do you know
what monkeys I've seen it yeah he heard
here oh you ready I've not tried all man
sorry dude we'll give you some movie
we'll get spoon up here yeah yeah yeah
so yeah you get milk peanut butter milk
will be out peanut butter peanut butter
chocolate milk will be out we'll call it
we'll call it very soon within a week
I'm gonna call it in a week cause you
order I don't had it and it's yeah yeah
see which kind of goes you think it's
counterintuitive to his whole you know
it's like hey let's make something
that's like you know healthy good
protein clean all this stuff but you
know what it has to taste delicious you
see him saying it kind of goes against
this whole hardcore toughness thing
right
just like the discipline you made sure
it tasted good Jim saying in that kind
of funny it's funny right you think it's
funny anyway yeah Molk good good one
replace your dessert with milk and boom
no sugar protein he's weirder there's a
substance on earth and you can replace
your steak and your dessert with one
item I'm not saying you got to do that
but six sometimes you get cooking a
steak is a pain sometimes it takes eight
minutes yeah you know we don't have any
minutes sometimes boom yeah makes it
walk your
come to the immersion camp we'll have
mocha the immersion camp in Maine August
26 through September 2nd dude it's the
immersion camp
yeah the wedge it to immersion camp not
Italian immersion camp because we won't
be spelt speaking Italian there no or
any other language is most likely maybe
a couple no Portuguese semester maybe
some espanol sure yeah you got any other
anyone else that wants to come and speak
other languages all the stuff that echo
just talked about origin main comm you
can get it there yep it's true also good
way to support yourself and the spot
guess if you want is the fact or knowing
that chocolate store and it's called
choco store okay how do you support
yourself with choco store if you want to
represent if you're on the path you want
to represent you can get a shirt says
discipline equals freedom to now new
designs on there if you care about that
so are you still offering the old one
yes that's an interesting decision what
I don't know because they're different
they're slightly different yeah they're
just you know hey okay so I have
discipline equals freedom shirts I have
the green one the you know the regular
and what do you call the head they're
great mm-hmm and what's the other one
like a charcoal yeah all same design so
I'm like hey you know if you care about
this kind of thing hey I'm gonna go I
don't know wherever the post office I've
got to post office like hey that's a
cool shirt you know your charcoal just
cool
I go to post office next day I'm wearing
the Heather one there he's like bro like
what up you just like that same design
so much you get it in all colors I say
yes but it's I'm still left with the
thought like man maybe I should get a
different design but I like discipline
equals freedom assume saying yeah okay
I'll come back to the post office the
guy is like hey I like discipline equals
room - that's dope
but I'm still he still has the sense
like okay he has more than just that one
do you night see me soon saying no all
right I do yeah I mean I know I'm kind
of overstating it but it's still it's
the thing it's not nothing
okay so I'll chocolate store you can get
rash guards t-shirts trucker hats you
can get other hats hoodies you can get
you can get legit hoodies and Hawaiian
hoodies hoodies if you know what
Hawaiian hoodies means which we don't
because Jocko made that up it's just a
lightweight hoodie you know it could be
called Southern California hoodie - no
yeah good
no sure sometimes it gets to be 38
degrees in Southern California the
Hawaiian hoodie ain't gonna cut it
yeah I think so and the less lightweight
they look nice
yeah and anyway if you want to represent
doclist or calm you like something get
something all the support also subscribe
to the podcast if you haven't you can
subscribe to it iTunes Google Play
stitcher if you leave reviews I read
them sometimes they make me laugh yes
that is good because they can be rough
but then you read it of good review that
makes you laugh that's positive so make
that happen
it works also YouTube by the way if you
like the video version yes
podcasts and a warrior kid podcast if
you haven't been listening to the
warrior kid podcast check it out it sure
it's for kids ask uncle Jake questions
there's some good questions in there you
got kids definitely check it out YouTube
you can see echoes legit supposedly
legit videos
oh yeah the excerpts yeah yeah cool but
also the ones you do your little fancy
stuff yeah yeah man again you're super
sensitive about video making everyone
should know that okay I'm not cool yes
anyone you made it you made the monster
video yep and someone this is an
interesting point someone put some what
I posted it to my facebook I pill I
posted there and there's you know people
commenting and then someone wrote no
credit to echo mmm that's it I thought
echo just dude he's doing his job and
he's get out of it yeah that's it
doesn't want that kind of credit yeah
um actually I think I made the video but
you did your job
yeah you're supposed to be good
congratulations well I think technically
to in I mean in the spirit of just
accuracy I think most people kind of
know that I made the video yeah like
because I just make the video that's
like the routine right that's what it
seems like anyway anyway I'm sure all
right yeah we're kid podcast is dope
that's on YouTube as well by the way
also if you want to vary up your workout
which i think is important thing but you
know hey people are people so and people
are different but if you want a very
upbeat workout try some new stuff I'm
gonna on it calm slash chuckle you get
some new gear gear in all capacities by
the way all the way down to socks you we
have the club to club heavy Club huh I'm
gonna have to check this out
yeah no no the club that you picked yeah
oh you like hair uses for juggling
you're like oh no that's not for
juggling you'll kill somebody probably
yourself but he's see that back to the
point that I said before about those
those are like oh yeah you know like
cool it's a club it looks like one of
those clubs that they juggle you know
the little pins or whatever guy yeah and
you pick it up you're like bro I can't
juggle that that's like something you
work out with and here's the thing
yeah there's full workouts with that
Club and there's varying weights or
whatever anyway you go to the website
you can see you know what workouts to do
a lot of good info on there you know
switch up you worked out man iTunes
Google Play mp3 you can get a
psychological warfare it's an album and
yes it has tracks and it's just me
telling echo and you if you're listening
not to be weak at that moment in time no
yeah he'll it helped it helps you not be
we're working on the second album well I
should say I'm compiling the thoughts
for the second album which would seems
like we've determined the working title
at this point is all your excuses are
lies yeah because that one seems to be a
hit home with me with everyone Jaco
whitey you can get it on Amazon in
Canada and in America you can get dry
tea little tea bags that you brew or you
can get the can
which we're gonna put all the big
unhealthy energy drinks we're gonna put
them out of business
yep that's the that's the prediction
sure cuz why would you not drink jock a
white tee why would you drink something
that's gonna kill you
when you can drive drink something
that's gonna make you more healthy yeah
and it tastes better and it makes you
feel better is it do you have any answer
to that I don't that's right cuz I'm
right if your your attitude is wrong
books if you're on Amazon anyways way
the warrior kid and marks mission and
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
if you want that on audio it's not an
audible book it's mp3 iTunes Google Play
all that other stuff and the extreme
ownership which was written by me and my
brother Leif Babb and it's about
leadership and we have a follow-on book
to that called the dichotomy of
leadership which is coming out September
25th and we're getting some feedback on
it right now and people are really
stoked
Lafe and I are definitely stoked on it
it's cool cool cool book to write it's a
little problem that little area that
it's the area that people have the most
problems with yeah how do you balance
between being too much of a micromanager
and being too loose how do you how do
you manage the being communicating too
much with the group and too little with
how do you devote how do you manage
being too close to your people or too
too distant from your people so all
those little things all those little
balances that you have to figure out as
a leader they're in that book check it
out
you can pre-order it anywhere if you
preorder it it's helpful because that
way our publisher who is you know just
not aware they're not in the game
they're not listening this actually if
they're listening this podcast they
should be thinking on you know what we
need to print a bunch of these books
don't miss out on the first two dish you
don't want the second a dish we might
end up with it if you don't order it but
and speaking of which for leadership
training if you've read the book you
need a little bit more inside your
organization national on front we solve
problems through leadership it's me wave
Babb and JP Janelle Dave Burke
Cochrane and now as you've heard my
brother Mike Cirelli
master 0:06 mustard 0:06 in San
Francisco October 17th and 18th Mike you
kind of talked about this but you're
feeling like the monster had will have
good impact on people it's it most
definitely is gonna have impact on
people it's been shown in just the two
days I attended I walked away I came
right back to Jordan I'm like I call it
I'm like dude don't call me dude yeah
like I'm blown away in fact the funny
thing is you remember there was a green
beret that came yeah and you know for
the listeners hey you know there's
there's strife you know rivalry rivalry
between the communities all for fun but
even he looked at me and he's like dude
this is amazing these guys are having an
impact and we were going to a very
unique place Silicon Valley
that is without a doubt one of the most
innovative places sometimes lacks
leadership as innovative products but
lacks leadership so this is gonna be
magical well yeah well that's one of the
things for one of the reasons is because
the companies we work with up in Silicon
Valley a lot of times they have the
technical capacity they're smart they
even have the business understanding but
the only thing that they need especially
once they start to grow is they need
they need better leadership and so
that's why we're the companies we work
up with that we work with up there we
know that they need this and so that's
why we're doing this one in San
Francisco October 17th and 18th come on
out you can register to extreme
ownership calm you'll see that on this
one you'll see like a lot of people from
the last one cuz they'll like keep
coming you know I mean because not only
that updates or whatever but just like
how you're saying earlier where the more
Kade you learn something then you go to
the field
you know you practice you don't practice
you perform then you're like oh wait
okay now it other problems arise yeah I
saw this problem that was other problem
yeah
because I felt differently no I see more
faith so boom I'm going back to the
muster yeah seems aim and then boom back
to the field so you'll see people there
every time she was updated and I'm gonna
tell you this so out of uh
0:05 this this police officer came up to
me
or I should say Mountie from Nova Scotia
say candy I want you to come talk
Department in India when he saw that I
spoke with the Louisville Kentucky uh
they which are my boys Police Department
measure of Police Department he's like
hey you need to come out
so we're coordinating I get to go out to
Nova Scotia look is a zero zero five and
that's all hospital they you know
speaking of law enforcement is we
because of the because of the popularity
of the muster and because there's
usually law enforcement military Border
Patrol firefighters paramedics all first
responders basically people in uniform
they've been coming to all the musters
but we wanted to do one that's a little
bit cheaper focused on those types of
jobs so we're doing something in Dallas
Texas September 21st it's called the
roll call if you want it it's the same
register and registered extreme
ownership calm you got to be one of
those you got to be one of those jobs to
come to that but that's gonna be focused
on that sort of dynamic leadership that
you get into in those situations so
that's the roll call
0:01 September 21st of course now one
more thing to talk about national on
front overwatch EF overwatch so check it
out real simple to put this out if
you're a veteran and you're either in
the military and you're getting ready to
transition out of the military
soft soft support combat pilots if
you're in that situation go to EF
overwatch comm or if you're a business
that wants to bring this type of
leadership into your team then go to EF
overwatch in you see there's real simple
instruction to follow and will proceed
to move down the path of putting the
best people in the best positions and on
top of that if you want to hang out with
us a little bit more virtually until we
see you in San Francisco at the monster
or until we see
roll-call or until we see you at the
immersion camp in Maine that we're on
the interwebs fully on the interwebs on
Twitter Instagram and Mike is MJ sur le
it's m je s a our our a I ll e that's
him on Twitter he's Mike sur le on
Instagram and he's Michael sur le on -
FAC bulky and of course echo is at echo
Charleston and I am at Jacques a Willie
kee echo anything else yeah yeah
actually so you're going back you did
mention you said mini buds did you say
mini buds that's what you went through
not but mini buds mini but so III think
it's called something that's gonna
announce now and I can't recall so
basically there is a vast pool of kids
in college and at the Naval Academy that
want to try out be officers in the SEAL
Teams yes because the competition is so
fierce the summer before they graduate
and actually become commissioned as
officers in the Navy they actually have
to compete for the few billets that
exist for buds officers good and so
you've got I think he anywhere from a
hundred to hundred you're actually
probably more than that trying to get
into many buds and there's only so many
I think like there's thirty per class
they run too many buds
every summer of about thirty candidates
each sixty total and there's probably
like five hundred kids competing for
those slots and then amongst those sixty
they're only gonna select I think like
fifty percent thirty that actually can
step into buds as Navy ensign and try to
become a Navy SEAL officer so you know
it goes back to that talent everyone is
always in a war for down looking for the
best candidates so you go to meanie buds
you pass then you go to buds basically
if you're lucky if they select you got
you perform well many buds
okay so and again this is just free
office for pipeline if you're enlisted
guy you enlist in the Navy and you could
you go to buzz there's no many buds for
you god they do have a prep course now
up in Chicago
after boot camp you you stay and you try
they try and get you ready for buds hmm
but but different of is yeah it's
different okay I don't think that's even
a selection it's not a selection and now
this lecture they could deselect you but
the purpose isn't d selection no I think
the purpose was to see if we can
statistically increase the number of
people that yeah through blood and I
think it's it hasn't proven effective at
the end of day it's just one thing for
whatever reason it's an eighty percent
attrition rate like almost all the time
or seventy to eighty percent so one of
my friends said this about butts about
passing buds that this is a fact it's
not the the tell-tale but this is a
factor where if you're in a group that
and this is gonna go back to leadership
by kind of interestingly if you're in a
group where people are real negative and
then you know when you you're negative
you want to blame other people all right
just if you're negative person whatever
you don't want take ownership so if if a
guy is seemingly getting ganged up on
you know like if everyone's like hey
you're not pulling your way you know
everyone's getting frustrated and then
they everyone's like harping on one guy
that makes them quit way quicker then if
like everyone's like yeah it's okay we
can do this you know how like you like
if you have a leader who's like hey it's
all good guys come on we got this
without this kind of trade everybody on
in saying like hey we're all we're all a
team here kind of thing but if you're
like hey you're holding us back and
everyone's ganging up on that guy he'll
quit way quicker that's what you saying
Chuck there's only one exceptional I
think that's probably accurate to yeah
for the most part there's only one
person that I think that I've seen sort
of defy that and that was Ron Joe yeah
you not getting that guy's head man yeah
and yeah tough as nails yeah seems like
that would be a a factor but yeah you
get breath there's just guys like that
and we're like no I'm not I'll die
before I quit you know it was just
simply not option no matter how deep you
go crazy yeah quit you know ask me what
what to do how to get through buds don't
quit that's it Mike any closing thoughts
yeah well yeah if you just people to
think one you know to you and all the
boys that I served with
across all the commands I served in many
it would it is a brotherhood while might
not have gotten along with all of you
definitely learned something from
everyone and it is a brotherhood that
you will never replace and that was an
honor to serve alongside those guys and
then I think the last two is one of my
kids Cameron and Caden I mean that is
any man's legacy is how you raise your
kids and they mean the world to to me
and then the last person who's changed
my life is uh my fiancee which I hope
you guys have reserved from the date
Jordan who's changed my perspective on a
lot of things and you know helped me
through a what is not easy for any
veteran is that that is transitioning
out of the military and I'll tell you
what her positivity is infectious and
she calls me out on my you-know-what all
the damn time she's younger than me and
it's a hit to the ego so thanks to uh to
that entire group and buddy yes awesome
man
well like I said of course thanks for
coming on and also like I already said
and which I can never say enough thanks
for your service in the defense of our
freedom you're talking about all those
deployments over and over and over again
man keep going back into the fray it's
freaking awesome and thank you for doing
it and congrats on your retirement I
don't know if I ever even said that to
you and you're retired but it's I'm glad
that you got to be able to retire and
it's awesome to be freaking working with
you again
so thanks Mike I'm looking forward to
many more years thanks brother and
everyone else in the military that's
still out there holding the line doing
those deployments over and over again
thank you and to the police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and Border Patrol and the
rest of you that are holding the line
here at home thanks for what you're
doing and to your families as well thank
you for supporting those that support us
and to the rest of you I know life isn't
perfect and I know life can be hard
but it is still life and it's your life
and there are those that have given
their lives so that we can have ours so
for them for those heroes live a good
life live the best life you can by going
out there every single day then getting
after it then until next time this is
Mike and echo and Jocko out